check one two one
two and we are live people of the
internets retro rack and tour here just
a dad who loves games and the stories
they tell guys welcome back to Harry
Potter and
the I was about to say Order of the
Phoenix Half Blood Prince is the one
we're on and I
thought I thought we were going to be
done in the last stream cuz we are going
for 100% we're trying to get everything
in this game unlock that platinum trophy
and we came up just I don't even know if
I can say just short like here's what we
still have to go we've got earned the
master duelist badge we've got to do
three dueling ones right here that's
probably going to take a fair amount of
time then this is something we
discovered near the very end of the last
stream is that you have to get like five
stars in all the
potions there's a lot of potions man
there's a lot of potions I was just
Brewing them I thought I just had to
brew
them okay so then we got that one that
one we have to unlock the final potion
which to do that we have to get more
Crest so the good news here is the the
broom flying the Quidditch is completely
done we're completely done with that so
today is going to be about dueling it's
going to be about collecting crests and
it's going to be about perfecting our
potions now I'm hopeful
that I'm hopeful that I actually have
the score I need on some of them already
but I don't know for sure and I actually
don't even know if there's a way to tell
you guys I don't know if there's a way
to tell or
not I know Dylan mentioned that you can
see like the crest you have but I don't
think that's going to tell me the score
of each potion will it but welcome in
guys thank you all for being here happy
Friday military man Sarah welcome in
Dylan
Danel always think I always want to say
Danielle but I think it's Daniel right
Danel Roma
kisi welcome in we got elwin in the
house too Arvin welcome back Arvin Gigi
good to see you here Jenny in the house
insh Z welcome back dude welcome back
Alicia is here as well ruie Marco King
Tut welcome in guys welcome
in much more reasonable
time well I hadn't originally planned on
streaming again this
week but
we didn't get the platinum on Tuesday
like I was
hoping so I stayed up late last night
finishing the most recent video which
just went live today if you guys didn't
know the uh Wizarding World theme park
in Orlando is is getting a major major
Edition next year completely new theme
park called epic
universe and it looks it it just looks
phenomenal man it it truly looks
phenomenal
but the Harry Potter section is going to
be Ministry of magic and also Paris from
the 1920s so basically the time that we
see it in the Fantastic Beast
movies so if you guys haven't checked
that one out yet make sure you uh check
it out I got to get it I got have to go
down there have to I haven't even been
since they added gring gots you guys and
the whole uh Dion alley
section all right so that's our only
save probably should have been saving on
more than one file just in
case you can actually watch the whole
stream no school on Fridays hey let's
go and eln gifting out the five
memberships I think the alert will catch
up here in a second but uh thank you so
much elen looks like GG got one of those
and Satish got one of those bill got one
of those it's flame and Anthony got one
of those and also boders UK L1 thank you
so much for the five gifted memberships
guys if you got one of those gifted
memberships make sure you thank eln and
also enjoy access to all of your emotes
now you get access to all the
emotes that we have here uh you can use
during the live stream you can also post
them on comments to
videos and a lot of people don't know
this one so I'm trying to talk about it
more but when you're a member you get
access ACC to our members only videos
which we usually post about one of those
a month uh kind of like little Channel
update personal life update
videos in addition to a members only
Community uh page sometimes I'll post
members only polls and things like
that yes welcome to the new members oh
yeah Special Discord role too if you
guys are uh into Discord
since we've been doing these live
streams again man we've been seeing a
little more uh little more activity in
the Discord always good to see you guys
in there hanging out and having fun so I
think what I'll do
first I think I want to try let's go
after the dueling
first and this game for some reason just
it's like it's extra loud so I've turned
down the volume even a little a little
bit more than
normal uh so hopefully the uh game
volume is too loud for you guys if it is
just let me know and I can make some
further
adjustments yes Dylan that's right we
very close to 60,000 Subs on
YouTube 60,000 man it's crazy so if you
guys are watching right now and you're
not yet
subbed if you enjoy the Wizarding World
of Harry Potter and you want to stay up
to date on all the news as far as the
games go as far as the upcoming TV show
the theme parks then you definitely want
to make sure you
subscribe it's
free a free easy way to support the
channel but yeah I think Dylan we we
should be we should be on track to hit
it by the end of the
day the way the way things were trending
but the way things go on YouTube man
it's a bit of a roller coaster so
sometimes you're like right now we're
having a really good few
weeks thanks to some uh Hogwarts Legacy
news that always
helps hey Kellen welcome back hey bought
Napoleon on your Apple TV wait what is
is that a is that a movie or a TV
show why are you trying to talk to me in
the middle of this
cave hey
harry oh wait can we not go down there I
don't think we
[Music]
can yeah K it sounds am amazing too I
mean I went to the one in Orlando years
ago like when they first opened
the the Hogs me section so that one is
at their park called Islands of
Adventure have you seen my chocolate
frog and so it's it was just like it was
Hogwarts obviously the big the big ride
in there Harry Potter and the Forbidden
Journey also the
uh I think at the time they called it
the flying unicorn
and then I think they eventually changed
it to hag's motorbike Adventure paranoid
but they had that there if I know their
real and of course they had the
restaurant and all the shops the W
olivanders all that but then a few years
later they built a completely new
section on the Universal Studios side so
Universal Studios if you guys haven't
been it's sort of like how Disney does
it with with multiple Parks is what
Universal's kind of slowly building
toward
so Universal Studios is a park Islands
of Adventure is a park you can kind of
jump back and forth between the two of
them so Islands of Adventure had the
first Harry Potter area then a few years
later they
did the uh Diagon Alley
section where they have a gring gots
ride more shops over
there and that I I H I still haven't
been able to go see oh yeah and then the
the other thing they also added the
train so you can like go back and forth
so you can like ride the Hogwarts
Express and now I think they actually
announced this park epic Universe in
2019 and there were some pretty strong
rumors that it was going to have another
Harry Potter themed area but then just
this week they finally unveiled the full
official details and so that section is
going to be called Harry Potter Ministry
of
magic and dude it looks so good it looks
so
good kisi yes I definitely want to do
more lore videos those videos they're
super fun to do and I think they'll be
ones that um you know they're not going
to get a lot of views the day I post
them but over time especially seeing the
response like I can
see uh the thing that YouTube looks at a
lot when it determines if people are
enjoying videos is how long people watch
the video so they call it average view
duration so I can see like exactly when
people drop off on videos and the lore
video is doing very very well in the
average view duration but yeah I've got
my my next lore video is going to be a
Hogwarts Legacy
one because there's a lot of stuff man
like I don't know maybe it's just
because I think too deeply about
it but no there's a there's a lot of
lure stuff in Hogwarts Legacy that
nobody's really talked about
yet like the one that I did about the uh
the 11 mysterious deaths I can't believe
no one had made that video and that's
one that uh Chandler they even kind of
said in their video they were like hey
why don't you guys see if we could find
these and still months went by and
nobody did it and I just realized no
nobody's done this I need to go I need
to figure that out but yeah this next
one is another thing that I found within
Hogwarts Legacy that's a pretty big lore
piece um on a character that is not
mentioned in the original series but is
mention in Hogwarts
Legacy all right where did Nick go I
lost him where are you off to now oh
wait is this where the is this where it
actually is the Gryffindor uh dueling
Club okay yeah Great Hall all right so
we need to find like a notice board or
something I'm guessing here we are at
your chosen destination glad I could be
of service so yeah kisi right now I'm
thinking maybe like once a month for a
lore video cuz those do take a little
bit longer to make
oh there it is over here by the
door is that confirmed ruy are they
actually doing a Wizarding World in
uh in England I know people have been
talking about it for a while but I
didn't know if it had ever been made
official or
not elen I would love that that would be
so
fun that would be epic I know uh James
is wanting to do something like that too
you just need to get a whole bunch of uh
Potter fans Wizarding World fans the GFF
Jun update on the TV show yeah there is
uh just last night hold on let me focus
and see if I can win this duel I don't
know how hard these are going to be plus
I've forgotten the
[Music]
Spells
I forgot um I forgot
what Lev Corpus
is hold on you can pause that's right
spell list here we go
dueling okay Pego is yeah I know that
one expell armus oh yeah and then
petrificus is you push them in Lev
Corpus is you
go both of them to the left
okay
leus yeah I think I like that wasn't Lev
Corpus hey Anthony welcome
[Music]
in there we
go all right I wonder if we have to get
a specific score do you know Dylan do we
need a specific score on these or do we
just need to
win oh I bet we I bet we do have to Five
Star them
all no
way oh
[Music]
no oh
no let's just do it again right now face
the Gryffindor Jun Champion all right so
what are they
actually basing this on me not getting
hit like like
[Music]
streaks come
on I need to hit with Lev Corpus or
expelling armor yeah there we
go all right so I'm going to I'm just
going to try not to get
hit and then try to get a nice streak of
attacks in a row on them after after
hitting expell
armas yep don't get hit there we
go all right that was I mean is there a
time bonus well done har because that
was pretty pretty smooth right
there oh wait good and great longest
chain and health
bonus oh no how do you get good and
great on
[Applause]
dueling griffindor all right let's go to
the next one here I give you Harry
Potter I know Anna yes surprise Friday
stream I got to get this platinum
trophy I was planning to finish it
Tuesday and we didn't so what is
that like a little area for them to oh
we've got one too to take
cover we got to figure out how to get
great so with the Quidditch games you
had to fly in the center of the
ring but how do we get a great score in
dueling maybe it's like a Direct Hit or
something I'm just going to really Pace
my shots like this see if this results
in
more all right let's see what
happens that was brilliant to you beat
her fair and square let's see what
happens
here dang okay only three great
[Music]
so wait a second I wonder if it's
different
spells maybe
Stupify okay you know what we also
should be doing guys because the game
doesn't really do a good job of telling
you I got to keep track of how many
stars I have in these okay so Junior
duel we got four
stars senior duel one we got three
stars this is just just like one of
those weird UI
things and then we've got to do each
house man this is going
to this is going to take a
while and then Champion
duel okay so my thought is maybe you
have to hit them with like expelling
armis to get a Harry Potter will face
the griffindor champ we're going to try
that I bet Stupify only counts as a good
[Music]
all right so I know they're probably
going to start off pretty
aggressive
yep corus okay there's a Lev Corpus all
right oh you can't keep hitting them
with
it okay this is super
interesting wait a minute you know what
else it could be it could be the
charging up the
spell could be that too
all right let's
charge oh no
[Applause]
way all right so that was round one
she remember beating all the houses and
calling it a day yeah that's I I thought
that's all we had to
do but as we've seen on all these other
ones for the
trophy they want you to get five stars
on
everything stop it quit hiding oh just
got hit by that it
backfired
[Applause]
I was about to say no way you dodge that
one too you won well done don't forget
to come back and try again I should have
counted how many okay we got eight great
that time that's it that's it you guys
oh my goodness and just let's go all
right so these aren't going to be too
bad
then okay so that one senior duel to
senior duel two we got five stars so
that one's done can check that one off
the list Champion duel are you ready to
take on the house Champion to become so
fully charged as well as expell armus Le
levicorpus those count as uh great
instead of
good oh come on get up get up get up hey
Wario we just we just got started pretty
uh pretty good here working on getting
five stars on the duels
here oh that's right it doesn't work
when these no there we
[Music]
go all right so levoc Corpus is
definitely not as good for this because
of or uh petrificus I
mean
but as soon as we got all those greates
it shot up so
quickly come
on there we
[Music]
go yeah that does a lot of
damage no way you dodged that
come on Harry about to lose this get up
get up get up get up get up hey Sam
thank you for
subscribing welcome in oh dude I think
we just
lost that's okay that's just that round
that's just that round round three you
never had one go to round
three that guy was just super aggressive
right there like it's not responding to
my
there we go ah see that I that was a bad
one I shouldn't have done that cuz they
just bounc off of
him
nice and the winner is there we
[Music]
[Applause]
goter okay so four great that's probably
not going to be enough for the uh yeah
and a low Health
bonus all right so that one we got three
stars but it is
complete dueling Club Champion badge
your dueling spells are more powerful
now hey that's good that should help us
out with the others and there's one of
the trophies
nice all right so
now oh man should we go ahead and
just we should probably just go ahead
and try to F star them all shouldn't we
Harry Potter will face the Griffin or
Junior Champion Wario I didn't at first
either I I figured out so Stupify just a
regular old stupy only counts as a good
hit but if you hit them with like expell
armis Lev Corpus petrificus totalis
those are uh come
on those count as great also if you hit
them with charge spells dude she was not
this evasive last
time oh my gosh are you serious right
now there we go that hit all right
charge it
up yeah that should end it
[Music]
nice and whenever we did this and we got
a bunch of greats the scoring just shot
up really really
fast nice end it quickly
here
all right let's see if it worked cuz
it's only going to be like four four
great maybe now you can take next
challenge okay yeah zero good four great
longest chain of
two are you
serious no way we ended it too
fast Harry Potter will face the
Gryffindor Junior champion that's
ridiculous all right so we got to make
sure we don't get
[Applause]
hit cuz that's going to help increase
our chain as
[Music]
well all right
nice
[Music]
dude this is going to be we're still
only going to get four great doing it
like
this o that was
close I'm trying to be more strategic
now I'm like waiting for her to Fire and
then all right so we didn't get hit at
all let's see what it shows our streak
at done Harry now you can take the next
challenge oh we got a good right
there longest chain was three Health
bonus 100 there we go all right five
stars on the junior duel
[Applause]
complete hey welcome to the new
subscriber
Danilo very sorry if I'm mispronouncing
that I give you thank you so much Harry
Potter guys if you're watching en Joy
the stream and you're not yet get
subscribed make sure you hit that
subscribe button especially if you are a
fan of the Wizarding World and enjoy
really anything Wizarding World related
Man theme park news TV show news gaming
news oh that just hit
us I'm just going to do a I'm just going
to finish
it wait
what
there we
[Applause]
go yeah same thing with the
potions right Wario I I don't see
anywhere that it it keeps track of it
that's why I'm writing it
down cuz apparently it's required for
the trophy
all right so we're going to have a
couple of goods on this
one see how the scoring shakes out and
sare what's with the shields you mean
those little those platforms or whatever
I don't know dude they just
appeared oh we're not going to get
it all right I guess I can't afford to
do
those I guess I can't for to do the
good Harry Potter will face the
Gryffindor senior Champion oh wait I
think I already did this
one it was the other one I needed to
[Applause]
get it
was uh this senior
duel and then also the champion duel
let's try to do the champion are you
ready to take on the house Champion to
become a new Champion then let's start
the
jewel this one could be tough I mean he
was pretty hard but it's not winning
winning is not the problem it's it's
getting the five
stars oh come on how did he fire
that oh man we got each other I'm just
going to
restart I should probably start doing
that a lot more are you ready
to the house Champion to become can't
even skip his talking either then let's
start the
jewel yeah the mini the mini games
they're a lot better than I was
[Music]
expecting okay wait for it there it goes
come on it didn't fire
correctly like how does he's doing that
every time that I fire my
spell he's waiting he's doing expell
armis to become a new Champion then
let's start the jewel I'm going to start
this one I'm just going to start firing
right away this
time see if I can hit him with a Lev
Corpus right away
leus oh look at
that
[Applause]
nice nice nice nice okay that should
count as a great as
[Applause]
well duel the oldfashioned way with
[Music]
fists I was just reading uh chamber with
my son that happens remember in the
first dueling Club Hermione and uh ment
bolod
or is it uh yeah I think it's from I
think it's
her dude every time I think we got him
though we got him and the winner is
Harry
Potter all right let's see no good eight
great nice come on
yes sir that was easier than the other
one all right so Champion duel five star
[Applause]
done all right so we just need that
second one senior duel one right here
Griffin doors I give you Harry
Potter I'm do the same thing with her
starting off immediately with Lev
Corpus come on
hit there it
[Applause]
is
[Music]
[Applause]
nice yeah it's it's fun reading to
seeing them experience it we actually
like we listen to the audio book and
read along at the same time
no I was afraid of that we're still good
we're still
good I'm going to wait and no let's just
fire
this all right let's see if that gets us
that was brilliant you beat her fair and
square let's see if that gets the five
star okay six great great that's
good it's not going to be
enough dude that is so close I think if
we didn't get hit I think we would have
had
it oh my griin why is this one harder
than the the final uh final
one all right don't get hit don't get
hit don't get
hit I feel like time should be one of
the ways they score it
[Music]
too but it doesn't appear that that's
the
case all right we didn't get hit there
and we used all
greats hey Christian gamer welcome in
things are going well just working on
this platinum trophy here oh my goodness
she just ran straight at
[Music]
me all right wait we're fine we're fine
we're
[Music]
fine oh that was my
bad right
there no we just got
hit why is she so much more evasive this
time dude dude
dude there we
go yeah levoc Corpus I feel like keeps
them uh that was brilliant you beat her
fair and
square keeps them at Bay a lot longer
yeah we only got five great that time
last time we got six longest chain still
three Health bonus was actually
worse wow look at that though it makes a
huge
difference huge difference right there
Griffin doors I give you Harry Potter
yeah if we could use more greates like I
guess we could just
wait instead of firing the big that's
what we'll do that's what we'll do all
right so this would count as a great if
we hit we didn't
hit come on it just does not respond
every
time oh we just we just took a hit I'm
just going to immediately quit out
we take a hit griffindor seeing that the
points are that close Harry
Potter jeez military
man that's
[Music]
dark oh come
on we just got hit by that
[Music]
[Applause]
one oh that actually hit
Griffin doors I give you I wish you
could skip this har Potter every time we
have to listen to
this oh no I Jenny I was just I was just
messing with
him I mean technically it is it is
something you could do in uh in Hogwarts
Legacy okay let's do a fully charged
one and then not not finish it out here
everlord welcome thank you for
subscribing okay so let her start firing
again now we need to hit with another
Lev
Corpus all right so that would be three
that would be three greates right there
I don't know how you could get more than
six greates I guess if you just wait and
don't don't hit at all when she's
suspended in
midair
[Music]
stop
it magic welcome
in finished work for the weekend time to
relax hey sounds good no no no
no okay I'm not going to fire anything
I'm just going to wait I'm just going to
try to stack the
greates yes there we go now can I
do okay you can't do expell
armis I'm try to do
petrificus it just bounces off when
she's suspended yeah dude look levoc
Corpus keeps them up
forever all right that that was now
let's now let's do a
Charged that was oh that was it all
right let's see how that one shakes out
I think we did take a few hits
but seven great let's see if that's
enough
no
yes it
worked it worked all right five stars
complete on every Gryffindor
duel excellent excellent excellent all
right we're ready to move
on you guys are just tuning in we are
going for the platinum
trophy and Harry Potter and the Half
Blood Prince on the PlayStation 3 all
right so let's do Slytherin next nichas
poton at your
service and I got to say they've been a
little bit harder than I was expecting
it's just these five star
ones you really have to uh be on your
your aame to get five starss in these
and understand how the point scoring
works because the point scoring they
don't really tell you you just you just
have to figure it out all right let's
see did we already get that yeah we got
that one come on
Harry going to be collecting a lot of
mini crests here
shortly that's another one that we have
to do here we are at your chosen
destination glad I could be of
service
all right so where's the little board I
think it's right
here all right Junior duel see I have no
idea what my score on that one
was I doubt it was five stars though cuz
we didn't know this scoring system think
you're good enough for our challenge do
you let's see how long you can survive
this all right so I'm just going to try
the same strategy
[Music]
here oh she's got a lot more Health look
at
that so I am going to go ahead and do
the fully charge
Stupify ooh dodged all
those oh oh oh
oh
slytherin's definitely more aggressive
it looks
like come on hit
what
nice I think that's it there we go all
right round one
complete
hey kisi with the Super
Chat thank you very much appreciate the
Super Chat kisi let's go retro let's go
trying
to take out these Slytherin
here
now
nice you ready for another one
oh no way no way you got for take off in
time that should do
it Ki thank you so much though always
showing love and support in the streams
very much
[Music]
appreciated oh yeah that's a good point
Warrior so this one should be the
hardest so if I get this one out of the
way the other should be nice getting 11
greats right there was huge we actually
hit the five star just based on the
greats all right so that was the senior
duel all right so we've already done
Gryffindor this is for Slytherin senior
duel is done so I'm put a little check
for that all right senior du senior
Champion Harry Potter do every Main and
side mission helps for XP oh you wait
you get gear in this game what I knew it
like upped your uh spell power and all
that oh
no I tried to block it but I was too
lateo what I don't think I timed it
correctly the
Pego oh come on stop
it you should not be able to keep
charging your spell while you're
moving oh wait I I can do that too I
guess I was like wait can I do
that now see
that I call bull crap you got she was
able to get that Shield up so
fast now see those are only going to
count as
good oh that's huge that's huge that's
huge we we win this now we win
this
all
[Music]
right ah thought I might be able to
sneak a levoc corpus in right at the
[Music]
start
no come on go go go
Harry there we go oh and then I got hit
by the xelly armis right in the
face oh come on we're both caught in the
same
spell come on
no you saw the Prego it was
up no way you're dodging
that
no oh
man and we lost let's going to round
three
dude that was a little
[Music]
cheap the move that's so frustrating is
how she can charge and still Dodge I
guess I can do that
[Music]
too there we go only powered up Pego can
block the advanced spells oh oh
gotcha like see how do
you you should not be able to dodge
that there we go I think we win I think
we win
here one
more there we go all right let's see how
the scoring shakes out though
[Music]
six good 11 great let's see how much it
11 great gives us on this oh yeah man
the greates the grates are huge okay
they count so many
points so many points when you hit the
greats so we can really even afford to
take hits on this one because they're
simply they have so much more Health
which means you have way opport now
defeat Harry Potter for hitting the
[Applause]
great oh if they made the the Hogwarts
Legacy honestly there are parts of the
system that I like I Hogwarts Legacy
spell system is
awesome but as far as like the dueling
goes there's definitely some things they
could they could take from
these like the controls on this I don't
I don't love the controls and it's all a
little little bit just like has like a
slight lag to
it ah we both got
hit come on break
[Music]
free like see how do
you
I can't dodge fast enough come on get up
get up get up oh dude he he wrecked he
wrecked us right there toward the
end he took the first round so we got to
we got to win two two rounds in a row
[Music]
here I come on move
car there we
go I don't even care about getting the
goods I just want to finish him off we
just got to win this
one there we go all right round two goes
to
us
no what are you doing
Harry oh
great watch him come back now imagine no
hey I'll take that actually gave us an
opportunity to score more points
anyway all right so I guess we got to
use the L2 and R2 to dodge a little bit
more against this
[Music]
dude nice nice nice all
right
oh that's
big yes straight into another Lev
Corpus all right I think we got
this let's just let's just let's just do
regular there we go all right let's see
how the scores
harryt he rushes out to get that
headline in
theer 10 great
man did you see the 17 good barely moved
it
nice it is all about the greats on this
one all about hitting those greats I'll
dare I say this was easier than the
Gryffindor one because they have so much
more health and now bear witness to the
victory of s's Junior Champion I don't
think I got a five star on this one cuz
I did it when I didn't understand the
scoring so
thank you Arvin thank you the trash talk
I know it's so
funny the Slytherin man they made them
accurate in this
game it took out a student in the
background did you see
that
no come on get
up get up
Harry
Nice all right there we go round
one this guy may actually be a little
bit harder to get the five stars because
let's see does he have not as much
health yeah he he doesn't have as
much
man they are smart they always follow up
the whenever I Proto they always follow
it up with an expell
armus oh I didn't know we could do that
if you time it just right and see look
how much faster you get up from expel
armis I'm still going to have time to
hit him with one of these I
hope very
nice right into the levoc Corpus oh
that's
perfect that's perfect only question is
it enough is it enough for the five
stars oh yeah that should be good 12
grates let's
go let's go all right Slytherin
done
five stars in all the
Slytherin let's see let's do Hufflepuff
next all right so Gryffindor dueling is
done slyther and dueling is
done Hufflepuff they're at the training
ground another adventure har off on
another adventure are we we are indeed
Nick we are indeed
becoming the dueling champion of
Hogwarts
here yeah these are probably uh this is
definitely more difficult than cross
wands I will
say definitely more difficult I guess we
are going for the five stars too
which UPS the difficulty a
bit just you watch
poter Mrs rakor hello hello
welcome Oh I thought we could break
that do you think Harry's the chosen
one
all right Nick lead the way
man I'm curious where this one is a
training ground or
something yeah I think so too Christian
gamer I think so it takes a little bit
too
long just dodging works out better
boiled beetles beetles beetles
beetles they're
everywhere man I haven't been seeing any
crests
either me take a peek in here Nick let
me just see if I oh no we already got
that Crest that was in
there so we still have a lot of Crest to
find that's what we need to do after we
finish off the
dueling because we need to find a couple
more crests to even
unlock the final potion that we need to
brew wait is that one up I see one up
there oh man what a weird
spot look at that you see that up
there okay hold on
I wonder if we have to go up the stairs
in here and look out virtual plays
welcome hope you're having a good Friday
so
far yeah let's go in here and let's go
up the
stairs ooh okay yeah we need something
to throw at that is there anything in
here that we can
throw CU I don't think we can get up any
higher zodiac how's it
going yeah this was a little uh surprise
stream okay
wait no I didn't mean to sorry Nick I
didn't mean to uh summon you
okay all right that's what I thought I
don't think we can
use I mean I'll try to use wingardium on
it but yeah I think we're too
far all right so we need to find
something on the
ground either in
here there right
there oh no this is going to be really
strange to navigate
though yeah yeah yeah right here right
here right
here oh next
window man if we miss
though this is going to take so
long okay the the controls in this game
all right all right all right line it
up bro you got to be kidding me can I
grab it again from up here
come on Harry look down
there come on
Harry oh maybe we can hit it from the
ground that'd be a lot
easier dung bombs there might be some
dung bombs out there too
yeah yeah I don't think it's going to
work from the ground you
guys that is so high
up there's a bench right there too maybe
that will
work like if I could actually aim up
there
maybe yeah I just I don't see how we're
going to get
that my Friday's going well so far
virtual thanks for
asking maybe if we go up
here I still feel like the best bet is
going to be from in
the okay yeah here we don't we don't
have a good angle on
[Music]
it throw a Slytherin can you actually do
that
imagine all
right oh that was really close
actually just wasn't quite High
Enough
oh
man uh CFC skills a lot of tips a lot of
tips I made a quite a few videos on it
here on the channel you could check
those out or if you have like a if
there's something specific you're you're
wondering
about all right let's try this
again come on follow me in
here ah
hi
Harry
okay all right let's get let's get close
to the edge don't fall off Harry please
don't fall off right
here yes oh my goodness thank you I did
not want to keep struggling with this
one
all
right 97 so we still have 53 Crest to go
that's actually
insane uh SE second try from the window
ruy we tried it we tried it a little
moment
before and then we tried it from the
ground but yeah second try I'll take
it all right to the training ground
hurry
all right Nick come on bust out the
Gears of War style Sprint here oh this
is it I could be of
service this is it this is where the
hufflepuffs duel okay where is
the where's the little notice
board maybe over here like in this
area
ah there it
is all right Junior dueling against for
huffpuff junior Champion so if we get
like 10 11 scores of great you're you're
Golden man you're set it's not a problem
to get the high
score oh see they have much lower Health
though look at
that you know what I might
do
expell armus yeah cuz expell armus they
get up
[Music]
faster then we'll hit them with
that okay so that one deflects
off oh we beat him already dang
it I know zodiac it's I don't know if
you've C caught any of our other streams
for this game zodiac but I've just been
I've been really pleasantly surprised by
this this whole game to be honest with
you I did not enjoy Order of the Phoenix
we recently did a playthrough of that on
the
channel you can find our let's play of
that and I just I was really
disappointed to be honest but this oh
wait can we keep hitting them with that
one while they're down no but right when
he gets up oh that's
perfect that might be the Strat
actually but yeah Half Blood Prince I've
been really enjoying it way more than
than I thought I would okay five
great that gets us up to the
three
no we only got hit once too man all
right okay hold on so we had a streak of
three we hit him with five
great so we just need to figure out a
way to get one more great in there which
I think I know how to do
it I think we do three expell armis and
don't we we can't get hit we got to get
the streak the streak
too all right so let's wait for him all
right right
now okay we missed we'll wait
[Music]
again now come on all right now we wait
for him to get
up
now nope too early there we go okay
that's going to be
two don't get
hit that's three cuz we had five right
yeah so this should give us six doing it
this
[Applause]
[Music]
way perfect
okay okay it's all right wait it
out
I'm getting greedy I should just
wait there we go all right see if we can
time it just right when he's standing
up now
[Music]
ah oh come on
dude are you kidding
me
[Music]
what there it is all right so that
should be six great we never got hit
don't forget to come back and try again
and so we should have the maximum streak
too
[Music]
longest chain of three nice let's go all
right so we're on Hufflepuff
[Applause]
now and we just got five stars on that
one senior dual one man I hope they have
more Health as they
go yeah but Christian gamer then it's
also easier for them to hit me too I got
to protect that that
streak
[Music]
I actually didn't mean to do that one
but it's
okay oh I got hit right there
man I'm getting getting hit too much on
this
one there we go all right one more
expell
[Music]
armis
ah we're not going to get it unless we
can get more than three greats on this
which we should be able to I think I
messed up by hitting her with the
petrificus yeah cuz she's got she's got
four
health
there's
[Applause]
one man it's perfect if you can time it
just as they're getting up and the
little invincibility wears off like
right now
no I think we got to hit too much to win
this to get five stars on this one but
we shall
see all right let's take a look
let's find
out okay so Arvin are you one who
actually
enjoyed oh let's
go did you enjoy either of the Deathly
Hallows games because I've heard nothing
but bad things about both of
them that's all I heard about both of
those games dueling veteran badge
congratul ulations
poter wait is that hold on is that all
the dueling
trophies I think that's all the dueling
trophies so we don't have to do every
one of
them I think I had to miss one oh great
we got to sit here and wait for this now
to sink like three
trophies M store welcome
welcome part two is actually good
Christian gamer said but one is horrible
oh man
all right well that'll give me that
gives me some hope they're both really
short too though right so at least I'll
just have to I just got to make it
through that's the main thing make it
through and and get the platinum
trophy call of yeah I've heard call of
Potter is a common nickname people use
for
them last one was good to you Gigi but
you've heard bad things about the first
one
we shall see we shall see I'm hoping to
as long as we can knock this out today
Half Blood Prince then uh we'll we'll
get started with part one on next
Tuesday try wizard Tuesday
man that's what I'm going to start
calling
it try to Target like a weekly a weekly
stream who knows maybe we'll expand it
to two weekly streams if you guys keep
enjoying enjoying two of them
but I like minimum one per week I feel
like one per week's a good balance you
never played any of them
zodiac it's a really interesting
experience I'll tell you that it's kind
of like a good look back in time at how
games used to be but also you get to see
a nice sense of
progression okay so yeah we do still
need Master duelist so we just got
dueling veteran right there Master
duelist that's the one so we uh we're
going to have to do all of them all of
the uh houses which is what we
thought come on let me out of
here why did my controller
just why did my controller stop
responding don't do this to me back out
please back
out I think it's trying to it's trying
to like bring up all my
trophies and it's not letting me back
out
no okay well at least it's letting me do
this
but maybe if we turn off the
controller then turn the controller back
on oh
no Lego Harry Potter games yeah those
are
solid those are
solid once I get done though with all of
them I'm going to do a big live stream
where we just I rank every Harry Potter
game it would be great is if by the end
of the year we had hit like 100k subs or
something and we could do oh my goodness
it just made us way through the whole
thing but hey it didn't lock up it
didn't freeze I'm good with that if by
the end of the year we hit 100K subs and
we do like a a 24-hour live stream I I
play every Harry Potter game or rank the
Harry Potter games cuz ranking wouldn't
take that
long but it would probably be a good
couple of hours cuz there's so many
games all right senior duel number two
now to take on the Huff which if you
guys are watching right now and not yet
subscribed to the channel consider
hitting that subscribe button it is
totally free over here on YouTube and we
are getting very close to 60,000 Subs
guys
so should hit it by the end of the day
actually really appreciate your support
okay so you're bringing out the big guns
here you're bringing out the powerful
spells my
[Music]
friend come on spell
armis come
on come on
Harry this is get let's try let's try
Christian gamer
Strat Maybe once we get him down that's
the way to
go come on oh
dude you might be on to something man
once we get them down that first
time
bro so the first one I feel like we need
to keep a bit of
distance but then after
that there we go now we go in we go in
we go
[Music]
[Applause]
in that is
[Music]
op that is op
man I should have listened to you the
first
time oh
jeez oh no oh no my spell did work
no it's all right we should still have
enough
uh come on sometimes it just because
you're like having
to there we
go yeah I should have known after I'm
saying it's too easy I would have at
least one of them
backfire all right 10 great come on come
on go go go go look at look at that
man all right so we're ready for the
huffle buff
Champion see the health bonus doesn't
even really matter if you get enough
greates to take on hufflepuff's house
Champion har
Potter so this guy he's probably going
to have more health I'm going to try to
hit him with Lev Corpus first cuz it it
fires a little bit faster than expell
armis
there we go just like
that oh dude that what that Point Blank
Range I think all three of them
hit cuz you know how it fires like a
burst of three I think all three of them
hit
dang it bad
timing like see watch if I just do
one we just hit him with one yeah
doesn't even come close to finishing him
off now we right here we right here
let's go with let's go with an expell
armas
[Music]
that should be at least like eight
great it may not be
enough
[Music]
10 oh yeah oh yeah look at
that all right helpful puff
done time for
Ravenclaw and then we will have the
dueling
trophy
[Applause]
yeah it'll be interesting to see uh when
we get news about quidditch
Champions unbroken has been been
relatively quiet this year so far I know
they uh have been promoting Suicide
Squad kill the Justice League
so I'm sure they are hard at work behind
the scenes on quidditch
Champions all right even call dueling
well this is good man this is not taking
nearly as long as I thought it was going
to for the
duels I'm tempted to go that way and
look
for actually I think I see one right
now to look for more
crests cuz you know we're going to have
to that's going to
be pretty
uh
sendio
monotonous wait what can I not do wink
guardium oh my
goodness it's so
strange it's like nope weard him
Leviosa not going to work on that
one all right we just unlocked the love
potion in potions Club is that the last
one we needed collector 11 let's
go all right Nick lead the way
now I think there was one like with Fred
and George though right lazy or lazy
welcome to the stream thank you for
subscribing to the channel moving us one
step closer to 60,000 subscribers guys
thank you so much for the
support this has been a uh I mean we're
in February now but January was an
incredible incredible month for the
channel just had had several videos do
incredibly well live streams doing
incredibly
well all because of you guys man can't
thank you enough for the support I know
we took a little bit of a break from
live streaming and a lot of you guys
missed it so that's the last one Dylan
oh
perfect boiled Beatles they're watching
us they're all watching to figure out
really what I wanted to do with streams
and where I wanted them to live which we
may still stream on Twitch occasionally
but pretty much anytime I'm doing a
Potter stream Wizarding World
stream it is almost certainly going to
be
here if you guys are just dropping in
for the live stream we are
currently on the uh dueling is what
we're working on right
now and so we've beaten Gryffindor we've
beaten Slytherin and we just finished up
Hufflepuff now we're heading over to the
last house Ravenclaw boys gets him
excited but not only do we have to win
these du we're having to get five stars
on them to complete and so it took us a
little bit to figure out exactly the how
the scoring system works well here we
are now we've got a pretty good handle
on it and it has not been too bad
so all right I'm just going to assume
that we didn't get five stars on that
one so let's go right back
[Applause]
in all right so not much health for this
[Music]
guy
armor
all right this dude can dodge that's for
sure come
on there it
is just like get up I dare you I dare
you yeah yeah try it again try it again
see what
happens no
no that's what happens that's what
happens when my controls mess
up oh
man like they work 90% of the time but
there's that 10% of the time that the
timing is just off for whatever reason
and it doesn't fire when you when you
press
it it's all right I'll take that trade
I will take that
trade are the crest pretty
tough
zodiac I mean we're almost at
100 which means there's like 50 more out
there somewhere like see right now it's
just
not just doesn't respond
sometimes following in james' footsteps
right get back up
you let's see if that's enough for the
five stars I mean since we've been
focusing only on
greats yeah look at that dude all right
Junior duel complete for
Ravenclaw senior duel oneing
up gaming arows your day going shadowin
by the way I didn't see you drop in
there shadowin welcome thank you for the
compliments on the logo glad you enjoy
it hope you're having a good Friday so
far
shadowin
oh oh that was bad I did get him with
expell armas
though nice nice nice nice nice
nice
super crimson red thank you for
subscribing to the channel
[Music]
welcome all right round two fight oh you
just don't like the repetitive thing
zodiac
yeah the the grindy type things elwin
thank you for stopping by appreciate
those gifteds earlier as well have a
great rest of your day
o all right he's getting aggressive man
he he's
[Music]
angry he didn't like our smack talk like
it's not working there we
[Applause]
[Music]
go oh it did it
again come on
Harry
I should just do a
[Music]
charge Point Blank
Range The Dugout football channel thank
you for subscribing as
well come on come on come on come on
nice
nice very nice very nice okay two more
to go two
more
3,962 and now what do you guys think
after
thisor you think we go we start Crest
collecting or do we go right into the
potions I'll let I'll let chat decide
Crest or or potions
we don't have to do a poll you guys can
just just comment there in the
chat oh come
on come on
hit there it
is all right I see one potion
there we got a crash
we got a potion so oh man you guys are
you guys are
50/50 it's
[Music]
hilarious I mean we're we're probably
doing we're going to do them both I'm
I'm locked in man locked in for this
stream I want to get I want to get this
platinum trophy
[Music]
complete well there's only one potion
left Gigi but we have to we have to Five
Star All the
potions and I'm pretty sure we didn't do
that on the majority of them I don't
know exactly how
many so the potions are definitely not
going to be a quick a quick one oh
there's a Crest right there speaking of
Crest see it over
[Music]
there this just feels so wrong
man oh I'm seeing a couple more crests
now I think crests are winning we got
okay we have potion
potion Crest Crest potion Crest
Crest I think Crest are winning by like
one or
two all right I think I can stop doing
the little check marks now I think we
got this we've got the Ravenclaw
Champion to go and then that should
unlock our trophy
for the master duelist to take on
ravenclaw's house Champion with this one
I think we might be able to afford to
uh let's see let's see what their
Health's
at eh
leus nice I'll hit him with the Lev
Corpus yeah see watch when you do this
all three of those hit when you're that
close like see that to me that is more
impressive than just standing there and
hitting a bunch of grates that that
should that should factor in
somehow they should calculate that in
their
points ah I knew I was taking a chance
of getting hit right
there there we go I'm just going to do
all expell armus for the rest of the
[Music]
hits
you've been speed
running chamber is that hp2 on PC that's
your favorite one right
Oreo Chamber of Secrets PC version oh
come on it's not working there we
go all right one more to be
sure
Wookie cookie welcome back that was
amazing hope you're having a good
Friday 12 greats I think that should be
good just from the greats
alone boom there it is oh you guys can't
see the number because the
webcam five stars though we got
it we got
it all right now let's see if it gives
us the
trophy
Master duelist
badge and the master duelist badge
trophy all right let's go
man complete complete complete all right
so I
think I think that Crest collecting
actually went out barely barely we did a
little vote in the
chat all right so let me hear for you
guys who have played this
game let me hear you your best Crest
collecting
tips because as far as I know there's
nothing that's actually going to show
us oh we just unlocked another one right
there that's
99 and then where was the big
one this one should be
100 all right get the
L okay all right we'll do that again
try that again excuse me oh okay hold on
back up back up back
up wait what hold on is there something
in here we can use that's going to work
better oh man there might be another one
of these I bet we need to hit the flags
again okay there might be a couple of
crests right here we can
get
[Music]
jeez
all right this
cauldron is making me
angry finally Crest number
100 all right see I don't know if I've
gotten this one yet or
not I bet I
haven't
actually I should be able to look up
there and
see we
didn't we did not get it but now we did
all right one a
one oh it's a tough call for which one
you like more The Nostalgia factor of
the first game yeah I mean what little I
played of the second
one yeah I was I was I was liking it
quite a bit all right hold on before we
leave that area we just
found two right there so I don't want to
leave that oh I just saw another one
okay hold on maybe this is not going to
be too bad
then we need about 50 more Crest you
guys see what does that bring us to I
think 1 10 three oh 102 okay all right
so 48 more crests let's go back out to
the Courtyard for a
second after I grab
these it's just like continuously
pulling me along
here I can't
believe is really B no all right so
that's the stone
bridge I love the little student
dialogue too I feel like there's a lot
more of it in this
game all right what is in
here ooh I don't think I've been in
here looking for a Crest do we have a
Crest I'm actually kind of looking
forward to this to be honest with you
cuz we haven't really explored the
castle
much to your guys's uh Point some some
of the critiques for this game are that
there wasn't as much exploration I just
feel like it kind of forces you along in
the story a little bit more which I
actually liked whereas Order of the
Phoenix was just way more
like way more open this one definitely
kind of pushes you along the story but
now that we're going for 100% we're
really going to have time to just just
really explore the
castle Paige plays thank you so much for
the uh subscription there welcome to the
channel man we got to be getting close
to to 60k you
guys so we were we were less than
100 when I started the
stream oh that's the bathroom where you
sectum simp
Maloy all right so let's just do a good
look around out
here make sure we get all of the mini
crests oh see they're dropping not
nearly as many
now okay that's where we just came from
that's
Transfiguration this is the
Transfiguration courtyard all right so
first I'm just going to hug this wall
right here all right you can't go in
there if you guys are just tuning into
the stream we are currently on a quest
to collect
crests a quest to collect crests we need
more all right so that's the grand
staircase
shortcut so we are just all about
exploring exploring the Hogwarts grounds
exploring the Hogwarts
Castle so this first step here is I just
want to make sure we have thoroughly
explored the Transfiguration Courtyard
and I
think yes you can keep H hitting these
but like it's just dropping so few now
we already did
that okay that one dropped a lot
more come on Harry collect
collect hey Derek welcome back flying is
done we completed the flying last
stream that one is out of the way and
then we just wrapped up dueling a few
moments ago and so now we are in the
process of collecting all the
crests and then we'll wrap everything up
with the five staring all the
potions which is not going to be
easy potions can be pretty tough and I
wasn't dude you guys I wasn't paying
attention to the star system at all so I
don't even know how it works man like is
it just is it just purely
speed is that all they care
about
oh there's one right there let's go all
right so let's lift you
up come on just a little bit
higher there it
is all right that's
103 time the halo around each object for
it to drop the mini crest
no way so they're all about the the
timing
of that's kind of a theme throughout the
game then
huh but it's sort of unspoken they don't
really tell you it's something you kind
of have to figure out for
yourself all right so we've already
checked all that section okay let's do
Grand stair
case and just make sure we have
thoroughly explored it all the way I'm
just going to start at the bottom or
let's see where it puts us when we go in
through here darkness and then we'll
just give a
thorough
exploration okay let's go wait how do we
go
down like Christian gamer and Wario like
should I should I bother with constantly
hitting
these or should I just focus on the big
ones cuz I feel like they're I mean
they're they're
everywhere just constantly be hitting
it o the Great Hall yeah we definitely
need to check the Great
Hall all right so very bottom of the
grand
staircase
and we are on the hunt for crests okay
so this leads you into the paved
Courtyard oh no worries Jenny no
worries uh Laura Anne first time
watching the live welcome in usually
watch it a few hours later replay Squad
that's all good appreciate the replay
Squad too but hey glad you're able to to
catch us live here by the way for
anybody who is watching this on
replay oh we need a we need uh we need
an Emoji guys for them to post did we do
the wand last week can't remember if we
did the magic wand yet or not cuz we did
a lot of dueling today so let's say
let's say three magic wands if you made
it this far into the stream watching on
the replay after the
fact post
three magic wand emojis in the uh in the
comments below the
video and that will let me know you guys
made it all the way to this
point in the
Stream all right hold on I want I don't
want to get too sidetracked and too far
away from the grand
staircase because if we keep taking all
these little uh areas where we can
Branch off that might be even worse so
let's just stay in the grand staircase
let's go back just start at the bottom
and go all the way to the top uh
Sergeant Bosch thank you for the
subscription welcome inff so
cute okay wait so that
one that one's more like a
circle every Crest counts so like I
guess what I'm confused by is do I have
to find a certain number of big ones or
could we literally just run
around only focusing on Mini crests and
get get the
max max that we
need three magic Wan
emoticons yeah that's I'm talking about
the one that everybody has access to but
um like there's an emoji that you can
use that's just like like a magic
wand but then we also have a for for
channel members yes you're correct we
have one that uh is like the Elder
Wand certain amount of mini Crest and
certain amount of big ones okay that's
that's what I was
thinking that is definitely what I was
thinking warrio that's a good point too
about people not about not having Ron
and Hermione follow you it does make for
a little bit of a quieter experience I
can't I I don't think I mind it though
to be honest it would be kind of cool to
have it as an option though all right
you guys were saying there was one up
top that I was
missing like in this area
Derek I'll give you a second because
there's like there's always a little bit
of a delay from from stream to when I
say it to when you guys actually hear it
I got that one already that's behind
that little
uh behind that right
there maybe I'm overlooking
one GG you're positive you can
get get it from both so wait so wait you
think you think I could just run around
colting mini Crest the rest of the
game not that I want to do that cuz I
feel like it's kind of
slow on the mini
crests turn okay hold on all right
because of the delay Derek just just try
to be uh give me more uh
specifics Because by the time you say
turn I'm probably already well away from
there oh I found it okay nice nice nice
nice all right
all right so let's go back into the
Great Hall and I'm just going to stick
to the Great Hall I'm going to start at
the bottom go all the way to the
top and we're going to see if we can
find any of the large Crest that
way also it hasn't been playing a lot of
the
uh mu I today so maybe we won't get hit
by the YouTube inquisitorial Squad as
much so frustrating man the last video
got had a lot of them so I basically
would just have to mute the whole stream
if I want to keep that video
monetized kind of unfortunate but right
now I've just left
it I've just left it with the uh music
in all right so let's start from the
bottom
work our way up
here all right any in
here okay so great Hall that's
definitely an area we need to come back
later and
explore all right let's go this
way all right that's a shortcut for the
potions class
okay I don't see any over
there okay this is floor
three they probably don't even have many
in the actual Great Hall or in the
actual uh Grand Staircase
area or since we've traveled through
this area so many times you know we I
would hope that we would have seen it oh
wait wait wait is that
one hold on let me
position okay nothing
there all right so we're at the very top
let's start with Gryffindor common
room a no Wizard Chest kind of sad they
took that
out I don't know why cuz they had like
they had so many so many mini games
included it's kind of crazy they didn't
include wizard chests
all right so can't go in that
side I think I got all the ones in the
common room
already anything up
there
okay all right common room is clear from
what I can
see let's go in this area
now floor seven all
right always got to remember to
immediately stop turn around and look at
the door behind you swamp witch Mia in
the
house Mia what is up welcome in happy
Friday to you hope you've had a good day
so
far my mom wants me to go home my mom
wants me to
go
home I have so many questions why does
she want you to go
home hi
har All right so we'll make sure to look
down that
Hall I mean we
basically we have to check so many
spots anything in
here
oo all right I don't want to check this
spot
yet 125 scattered around the world and
then an additional
25 big Crest from the mini Crest gotcha
okay so I wonder if we can tell is there
a way to
see oh my goodness so we only have 14 oh
my goodness you
guys this is
bad we only have 14 out of 25 on the
mini
crests oh
goodness we we may not be able to finish
this stream you
guys we may not be finishing this stream
after all so to answer my my own
question earlier should I be hitting all
of these yes I should I should be
hitting every single one of these mini
Crest that we come
across my goodness
man it's going to take so
long I wish there was an area where you
could just like Farm
them I mean they are everywhere but it's
oh that one gave us a lot let's go let's
go let's go
Arvin no I never played uh I've never
played prisoner on on
PC I've played all of philosopher stone
on PC a little little tiny bit of
chamber on PC but have never played any
of uh prisoner basan on
PC another live I mean I was definitely
going to do another live but I was
hoping we'd be ready to do Deathly
Hallows part one on Tuesday
but and at this rate I don't know we
might be another uh might be another
half blood printin
stream all right so that floor I feel
good
about I
really now let's start right here I mean
we just we we got to be hitting all of
these
guys I wish there was some kind of spell
that would just automatically draw them
to me like do I actually have to walk
over each one oh that was a lot that was
a lot let's go give me all of those
please man we haven't seen any big
crests in a while it's about time though
I feel feel it I feel it there's there's
one coming
up there's going to be one coming up I
wonder if I've gotten this spot
yet oh is this the room of
requirement we didn't get it but now we
did let's
go xcali Bros thanks so much for
subscribing to the channel welcome
welcome
Yow she said
yo sorry about that man got to get these
crests you know got to get these
crests all right so we're at 90 out of
20 Okay so we've got 35 more big crests
and then 11 more mini crests dude we
might finish the big Crest before we
finished all the mini
crests that's crazy to
me
all right should I go
down H I guess we should let's I I
remember this this area though and I
think we already got the crest that was
in
here
hold on check behind me always make sure
there's not one above the
door you have to time the
Halo
like like that Halo I don't see it
moving at
all sometimes I see it pulsing like
you're talking about
yeah what what am I like right there
okay now see wait hold on back
up I don't see it
moving right as you come up to it okay I
do see that and it'll shrink to normal
size what hold on let me scroll back up
and
read right when the Hal is at its
largest that is
crazy yeah so it's right it's like when
you first oh dude that is Christian
gamer
that see I thought I was doing something
wrong cuz I saw your comment but I'm
like when I stand here and look at it I
thought they would like keep
pulsing so that basically means as soon
as you see the the circle watch for it
to get as large as it can like that
I miss time on that
one all right this this is potions right
here isn't
it all
right Horus anything going on here my
man any Crest in here
Horus more Felix for ingame
right that would be
amazing all right so nothing in
potions man and you see it it can like
there's so many branching areas I'm like
which way do we go to keep
exploring okay I remember this area and
I think there was one there was one in
here somewhere I'm pretty sure we
already got
it so as soon as I start seeing that
little Halo
oh my goodness it's so dark wait what is
this you
guys what what some sort of secret
passage you had a dream the other night
Draco was trying to kill Hermione me
Harry and Rod had to stop him oh my
goodness Mia that is
hilarious
oh Slither in common
room
yes that makes
sense there's like or no wait that's
slyther in common room right maybe this
is like the exit or something I don't
know all right okay so we can cross this
area
off we explored all of that now let's go
in here okay I remember remember this
area there was a Crest there that one's
gone we're
good you guys this is going to take this
is going to take a long time we might
should have focused on
the maybe I should have went for the
potions first we could always take a
break and do that it's probably good
that we did pick the crest first so
maybe we can get like a nice start start
but I can't see myself enjoying just
repeatedly focusing on this
so that'll give us a nice break here in
a
bit Yeah you want it to when it's at its
largest GG is what Christian gamer said
so like when I first walk up to it see
if this one does it like see I was a
little bit off I was a little bit
late P Puffs are so cute okay let's try
it on this one
that one was a little bit
better basically like as soon as you see
it start to
appear o I wonder if we've got this
one I think we did I feel like I
remember this
hallway
nope yeah we got this
one
all right Viaduct
entrance priest
Nicodemus thank you for subscribing to
the channel man been having a lot of
Subs coming today guys thank you very
much appreciate the
support oh that one we must have timed
perfectly look at that like just think
you guys how how long you've seen me
collect and we haven't gotten
any of the big
crests oh my gosh guys this is going to
take I may have to seriously do this off
stream like throw some music on and just
or throw a video in my other monitor
over
here we still need 11 of
[Music]
these okay we were just in here earlier
the good news is like they they come
back like you can basically spam them as
much as you want it seems
like I no Arvin
right hey speaking of the one year
anniversary you guys got any fun video
ideas like what would be a cool video
you all would like to see me make for
the oneyear anniversary of Hogwarts
Legacy cuz I have a bunch of ideas but
I'm just like I don't know what would
be I can't figure out what would be the
the most
interesting cuz like you know we could
do like a one-ear looking back
retrospective but I don't feel like that
would interest a lot of
people I was hoping they would drop some
sort of news on the Oney year
anniversary but the fact that they
dropped the news oh well hello there
there's just random Crest right here
I'll take
that all right I needed that man oh and
another one let's go I needed
this I was getting
discouraged all right 106 9 nice nice
nice like see it'd be one thing if I
already had all of the the bigger ones
knocked
out we don't we still have 40 what was
it 45
44 they reset after a certain amount of
time
yeah oh there's another one okay so the
fact that we've gotten three really
quick I feel like this means this is an
area that we haven't really explored
thoroughly
so I'm just going to continue going down
this
path see where this leads
us oh come on that was on
there that was on
there that dude is like what is he
doing come on man don't you see the
crest why is no one else interested in
these why is it just me
why is it just
hairry I'm going to have to look this up
later man is there nothing that gets
them
faster you would think there'd be like
an like a couple activities where you
could really just go
crazy and they would give you a ton of
the little mini
crests
oh that was good that was a good one I
we still haven't gotten a big one you
guys we got one a little while back we
we got
one but we've probably been playing for
15 minutes collecting just about every
mini Crest that I
see and we haven't gotten another
one yeah that that section was awesome
Christian gamer that that gave us a
lot oh finally there we
go sheesh
man so there's probably a total number
of mini crests that we need right it's
probably like 20,000 15,000 or
something all right so we're at 93 out
of 125 on the big the big Crest going to
win theid Cup this
year let's check the the great
hle we've been in here a couple
times like see that was that was
terrible right there we barely got any
from that
one that was a little
better I thought about that Mia that
that could be a fun idea that might be a
fun
stream somebody said um Jenny said love
to see blooper gameplay bloopers and
glitches from like all streams or my
yeah all streams would take forever like
my
streams sadly a lot of them on Twitch
are probably uh
deleted because they only keep the vods
live for I think 60 days or something
like
that but yes we had we had some very
funny times with
Legacy just Spam it like crazy in a big
area yeah I could see that oh can you
not go in here in this
game all right so that's one less spot
we need to worry about
exploring okay so I feel like we need to
go back into the grand
staircase and we need to go up to like
floor
three and the Char
and he's the chosen
one yeah we are going to be doing a live
stream on uh james' Channel next week so
for you
guys who know expecto
go be on the lookout for that I think
it's the
seventh it's kind of crazy man that it's
been a
year don't you guys think so I mean does
it just does not feel like it's been a
year okay floor one I'm pretty sure we
already looked around here yeah yeah
yeah
okay hold on how do we
get potions class shortcut okay we were
just at the potions area I'm not going
back
there this will be floor 3 I believe so
we'll go in here I don't think we've
checked out floor 3
yet ooh that definitely had
one
baggy boo welcome how far along uh well
we've beaten the game so we're done with
that we've five start all the
dels we have five starred all of the
Quidditch so now we're on a Crest
collecting hunt hey har and then we also
need to Five Star all the potions
and the crest collecting is taking a lot
longer than I was hoping it would
dueling went a lot faster than I was
expecting Crest
collecting I mean I should have known
right I should have known let's
collectathon all right do we have to
knock this one free yes we
do excellent excellent excellent okay so
that takes us to
94 out of 125 for the big
crests feels like a lot less than year
yeah I think
so I think so
too what do you guys think we're going
to get for the uh the summer
update let me hear your
theories let me hear your
theories because I think there's going
to be a
surprise maybe it's just wishful
thinking
but I mean I'm expecting if you guys saw
my video on this then you already know
but if you haven't I'll tell you I'll
tell you here in the live stream they
clearly want you to see that it's it's
not just GNA be like bug fixes because
if that's all it was gonna be they would
have left it at they would have said
like minor updates
or bug fixes patch notes things like
that and they said updates and
features he so they they want you to be
like okay it's not
just it's not just a a little small
thing but it also seems like they wanted
to set expectations to where people
would not expect some massive
DLC now the reason I think there could
be a surprise is because you look at
games like uh ghost of sushima God of
War God of War is probably the most
recent one in recent memory it's just
like no like they just they just dropped
that and people couldn't
believe at how much they put in there
after they had kept it relatively
quiet so that's kind of my hope is that
it's something that nobody's really
expecting
because because we're just you know
setting our expectations low uh we got
to back up a bit but I do think yeah I
think you're right Christian gamer I I'm
thinking I'm thinking things like a new
game
plus things like a photo
mode maybe some little quality of life
features that like I know so many people
want to be able to just sit in the
game that one always makes me smile cuz
it's just it's just one I personally
don't really resonate with but so many
people want that so many people and I
feel like that's something that would
be not too crazy to to figure out and
then I'm hoping maybe we'll get things
like uh like crossed wands where you can
can do more levels of crossed wands and
where it stays like if you want to
repeat and do it
again like I mean kind of like in this
game to be honest like how you can do
those
dels and how you can go for high scores
like honestly just the little high score
element in this
game it's such a small thing and I'm
talking about Half Blood Prince here
it's such a small thing but it's such a
great
little something else that people can
chase for you know something else that
people can uh it gives you a reason to
keep playing and so many people
that's what I keep seeing is they just
they just want to reason it to go back
and like hang out in that world hang out
in hogwart's
Legacy so like cross wand summoner's
court maybe a few more uh
opponents okay that door's completely
locked can't get in
there one thing I will say about New
Game
Plus and I'm even somebody who's been
asking for
it I can see why it would take them a
little bit longer to get a new game plus
ready because think about the way the
progression works in the game like you
start
out you don't know I mean you have
barely any
spells so they would have to figure out
okay do we want to give them cuz
typically in New Game Plus guys you you
carry over most of the abilities that
you unlocked in the game that's how it
works so it's like would they just give
you access to those things right away
and then if they
do do they tie something into the story
that lets you just skip it like cuz like
learning fendo I believe that was a
lesson with garlic to learn
fendo so like if they take that out if
they give you fendo
already do you just like not have to is
that I guess that lesson was optional
anyway but some of them were required
like I know incendio with
uh with heckit was required so I guess
you'd still have to do the required ones
yeah the varium system yeah yeah yeah
yeah that's that's one that I feel like
could definitely be expanded with more I
mean more creatures more
items so I feel like most people like
looking from what you guys are
saying I feel like most people have
their expectations kind of in a
reasonable place but man if you guys
some of the YouTube comments on my video
about it
buddy some of those people are going to
be very
disappointed they're they're talking
things that I'm like that would have to
be a full-blown
sequel a full-blown sequel to make some
of that stuff
happen all right we need to get that one
up
there okay there's the charms classroom
I don't think I've explored there can we
not pick that one up let's see we should
be able to get this right
here follow me follow me follow
me all right back up hey
harry sorry we're trying to get these
crests
here you have just unlocked two player
dueling pack six something about the
paved
Courtyard press collector
12 all right I at least like the
progression there they're giving me
trophies along the way to keep
encouraging
me because man let's just go in Charms
first when you see how many you still
lack there we go there's another one yes
Flitwick I was hoping you'd have one in
here
man all right Flitwick thank you
sir oh there's another
one I'll I'll take that easy one any day
very nice so that was two here in
flitwick's classroom can we talk to you
Flitwick like how's your day going man
no no okay all right see you
later 100 so we need 25 more of the big
crests man this is this is a grind that
is for sure
if I can get to 25 then I think we go
do we go do potions but depending on the
the speed at which I I gather them I
might have to do it
sooner just to keep just to keep myself
from getting too bored with the crest
collecting oh easy one nice that's what
I love man give me more of those
give me more of those where all I need
to do is literally just run by
it oh did I
see oh I think it was just the window I
thought I saw something like on top
there oh there's one right there nice we
know how to get these now break it oh
okay all right that works not really
what I was
not really what I was trying to do
exactly
but okay any more in
here all right what's that 20 23 all
right all
right
25,000 okay that one I'm doing off
stream I'm doing the mini Crest off
stream that is so ridiculous man 20
25,000
what like through the whole guys we're
at
6,000 holy cow that's
insane that just that just depressed me
Christian
gamer that just depressed
me baggy that's a good question I don't
know
I feel like just the one ones behind
bars but I don't know that I've really
tried to do it with the
others all right guys what do you think
next so this was floor three that we
were
exploring like if they're going to make
you collect these then they at least
need a spell that
just an unlock that just automatically
draws them all to
you that is so annoying that you need 25
that is that is mindboggling it really
is like see I don't even know if I
collected all those I don't think we
should come
here all right so let let me check right
here I think we got I think there was a
Crest right there that we already
got does this take taking us into
astronomy wait what is this like the
Upper Floor of the
library can you not get into this from
down below oh there we go I bet that
does go into
astronomy all right yeah this is the
room I remember us being locked in here
before each Crest in order yeah I think
you're right I think you're right it
requires more to unlock
it which is
unbelievable seriously
unbelievable astronomy
tower all right let's go all the way to
the top
first there should be an area where you
can just go and get an insane number of
crests
oh there's got to be one up here
somewhere no way there's not one in here
right okay wait that would take us
back is there really not one in
here it's kind of surprising
in here maybe oh no this is where we
just
were all right well I feel like there's
going to be a lot outside in the like
Hogwarts grounds area cuz I haven't
really explored explored that too
thoroughly I don't even know what I just
cast the spell on but I don't see any
crests to collect
all right I don't even know where this
goes but I'm taking
it hey that was pretty good right
there Christopher thank you for
subscribing to the channel my
friend Happy Friday go away poter all
right we were already in this Hall I
remember
it yep there's charm
okay let's go
here let's go outside I'm tired of I'm
tired of struggling in this
area oh my gosh M store
yes where's ravello when you need it or
even something on the map just to tell
you even if it just told me the
area that would be a huge help but you
get nothing
nothing all right herbology we'll
explore that right after
this no
more all right so we must have gotten
that one
already let's check
hology I mean it is good that we're kind
of kind of mentally checking these
places off cuz we know we got
charms now we're checking
herbology we we did
potions one that we haven't done would
be defense against the dark arts
though Transfiguration I don't think we
went
into the Transfiguration
classroom I don't think we've done the
boat house either GG I feel like most of
them the big ones that we have left are
going to be in the outdoor
area at least that's what I'm telling
myself with my fingers
crossed all right since we're here I'm
going to take a peek at the
potions I'm going to take a peek at
these scores because I wrote
down actually I took a screenshot
of the required scores that we
need all
right the required scores for five
starring I'm just going to go ahead and
write all these down one through 16
here six 7 8
n you can't make this up I had exactly
16 Lin left on my paper that's crazy all
right
so volubilis we need 1830 we have
1714 shrinking
solution we need
1738 we have
1656 wit sharpening wit sharpening we're
good wi Sharp sharpening we need
1066 and we have
1080 all right so wit sharpening
done uh let's see draft of living death
21 oh wait cure for boils
1636 we're going to need basically all
of
them basically all of them
I forgot to be writing down the numbers
so I can still see you guys in chat let
me write all these down all right cure
for boils
1636 uh draft of living
death we need
2195 we're at
1928 the giring
potion
21 or no
33 antidote to Common
poisons
antidote
common poison I'm just going to write
them all down and then I'll go back and
check
2908 uh draft of
peace
2291 the Oculus
potion
1843 the wizard uh the Love Potion
2860 poly juice 216
three Elixir to induce e
Foria
2193 Love Potion
antidote
2629 like who came up with this scoring
system man fertilizer
is
3230 stamina
game
3550 and then Wigan
weld 30
53 man all
right
wait you believe what gives you big
Crest
Dylan oh casting incendio on the
fireworks what no
way Clint what's up dude welcome in good
to see you
Clint all right so giring
potion we do not have enough antidote to
Common poisons oh we do have enough on
that one let's go all right
antidote common poisons complete my pen
is
dying all right antidote is done draft
of Peace we need 2291 so close Oculus
potion 1705 that's not enough The Love
Potion obviously not enough we haven't
done it at all poly juice 2163
2309 that's we're done with that one
excellent The Elixir to induce you
Euphoria we do not have enough love
potion antidote I could read my writing
here we do not have enough fertilizer oh
my gosh fertilizer we need
3230 and we're at
3224 stamina game we were horrible on
that one we need
3550 and then Wigan well we need 3260 or
3053 we got it so we're done with wig
and weld all right so of all the potions
we've got four of them
complete there are five firework boxes
you can cast incendio to get the big
Crest oh that's
excellent that is excellent because I
did it in the
mission but I don't know if I ever did
it to
um to actually get any
crests man all right I think I'm going
to I think we're going to let's let's
start working on some of these potions I
want to see how hard they're going to be
because well valous SE where at
1714 1830 I mean is what we need so not
that far all right I'm going to take a
quick break guys
so feel free to run and grab a snack
grab a beverage I'm going to go get a
Cherry Coke say hello to the kids I
think they got home from school and then
I'll be right back and we're goingon to
we're going to keep going ahead I'm
going to I'm going to try my best to
knock this out today we'll see we we'll
see all right one moment I'll be right
back
guys
[Music]
for
e
[Music]
for
I didn't realize you could still hear
the
uh that's funny that I still had the
game audio in the
background
all
right a fresh Cherry Coke
Zero ready to rock and
roll got a banana here to snack
on I know one is on the staircase next
to the boat house yeah yeah yeah I think
it was during slug Horn's party all
right so our goal here is
1830 for this potion theous potion is
one of my favorites 18 people use it to
play tricks on others to change their
voices which seems a waste of to do we
really have to do this every time okay
no we don't need that to start so what
do you guys think they would how would
they judge these I feel like
time and also so probably how accurate
you
are make not making any mistakes okay
right there stop all right this
[Music]
one right there
Min I mean I don't know what else other
than like not making mistakes
time and then the exact accuracy like if
you get the color just right stewed
mandr quieter than the live
[Music]
version syrup of
helor syrup of
hore all right two heating it
up come
on there's the
red and then this one I think we just
keep going and I think it will
automatically stop no it doesn't
care we only h two
greates oh no man oh no no no no no no
final score was 1629 we need
1830 what how do you get
what how do you get great in thisis
potion is one of my favorit dude that
was like that was perfect except the end
to change their we did mess up at the
end which seems a waste of a good potion
to
me oh my goodness
man it must be based on getting the
exact color like see that's a little
deeper of a red than what they
showed right there
stop this is going to annoy me so much
which I can already
tell because it's it's it's nebulous
like there's no there's no clarity as to
what exactly I need to
[Music]
do we need to look for cues though
there's always cues maybe we need to get
that music where it's like ding
ding see we didn't get it right
there
[Music]
didn't get it right there
either but maybe it only plays that at
the
[Music]
end I also need to figure out which one
gives you like the
most oh see that one did that one did
did you hear the little
dingding
stop okay nine good only two
greats oh oh
no oh this is going to be a
pain this is going to be a
pain how did that not get it man
favorites some how did not get it tricks
on others to change their voices which
seems a waste of a good potion all right
so let's listen this time we want to get
the
ding-ding we want to get the ding-ding a
lot didn't get it right there
okay got it right there all
right did not get it
there okay so what is that
one that's
[Music]
two
come
on yeah I knew I needed to stop it
[Music]
earlier
nope how is that not it
man oh three all right come on
[Music]
four only four am I right
yep all right all right all right all
right that's only the first
potion that's only the first
potion oh my goodness Marcus what's up
welcome in
all right so we got we already did wit
sharpening on this one we need
1738 on the shrinking solution
1738 okay so these
guys
one
two
three okay so that one I guess is like a
free
GR ah too long held it too long shrivel
fig come
on watch out I don't understand why
that restart it restart
it what was it shrinking solution yeah
crabs should take some of
[Music]
this so as long as you don't miss I bet
you get a perfect on
these
nice there we go all
right okay kind of that teal
color
I'm telling you man there's a slight
delay it doesn't stop the second that I
let
go so you almost have you have to like
guess just a little
bit okay the little one here till it
turns
green come
on okay these guys
oh I almost
missed nice okay now we're shaking the
purple one again but we're running out
of
time come
on
all right heat it till it's
green
stop five great
that's yes let's go all right shrinking
solution
done wi sharpening is done cure for
something about
boils cure for boils all right we need
1636 on this one looking at that I think
I'd rather have Bo
[Music]
1636 like as soon as I see it turn red
I'm letting go right there and that
wasn't even
enough there we go that was good
mut come on
[Music]
dude they do not hand out the greats
easily snake fangs luckily powdered and
no longer attached to the
snake porcupine
CL
oh
nice nice that was another one all
right's let's finish Strong finish
strong there we go oh great finish dude
look how it shot
up Great Scott I think he's figured it
out care for boils
done Dylan did you do this back when you
played did you did you go and get five
stars on all these okay this one there's
a big discrepancy man we need
2195 and the first time we beat it we
only got 1928 so not
great saporous
beats come
on a light purple oh held that one too
long it went much faster than I was
expecting like that
dude oh this one we're not going to get
it come
on this
one yeah so far zero
great
there we go
finally all right it's a good streak we
got
two held it just a little
long oh come
on like
what
wormwood
how is that not
it oh nice all right come on finish
Strong finish Strong finish strong light
purple light purple right
there not enough oh
oh
okay
okay that was that was very solid right
there I will take that you played on
PS2 oh you remember collecting the
badges okay so all of this
page
done okay Gertie potion we
need can't tell if I wrote 22 or 21 but
we need a lot more than I I got that's
for
sure no not you that's going to count
against me isn't it even though I didn't
mean to pick it
up it did it didn't it didn't do the
little
ding ging potion can get a bit
smelly
let's see if it does this
time that is
crazy come EGS so just for me picking up
the wrong thing
first it did not count it as a
great okay I think maybe I'm pressing it
too fast cuz I've been just trying to
hurry through
it I'm going to be a little bit
more
strategic like up down up down up
down ah didn't hold it long enough
though okay three of
these come on don't
miss don't
miss
nice all right don't miss these
are these are the ones you got to
nail
Perfect come
on six great oh they didn't
oh we still got it nice like see that
time the goods barely did anything on
that
potion all right so we already did the
the antidote for common poisons we
actually got lucky had that one our
first time so we are ready for draft of
Peace oh we were really close on this
one we need 2291 of peace I wish it was
peaceful to make I always end up setting
fire to things when I make
it okay bottle right
there oh the
stirring I forgot we haven't had any
stirring
yet
what I don't know how that wasn't
right there we go I needed that
man we're running out of time on this
[Music]
one oh that was
good man you got to be quick on this
[Music]
one
whoa I don't understand that
man well it's a start you'll get it next
time Mac the manager Mac welcome
[Music]
in all right I need a trophy I'm just
going to do this one on this one we need
jeez it takes
forever how is that
[Music]
not oh that was big back to back all
right
a little more a little more a little
more right there now
red right there nice we needed
[Music]
that okay kind of like that teal green
again
getting
close
there
nice I tried to stop it
sooner
[Music]
and the stirring takes
forever that
is oh my goodness
[Music]
okay nice Strong finish strong
finish Strong Finish
[Music]
there we go there we go
man come on yeah nice all right so the
Love
Potion complete and we got five stars on
it now we've completed every potion at
least once so that should be good enough
for a bad right here let's
see and
also a
trophy all right good deal good
deal okay so which one did I skip there
that I wanted to come back to oh yeah
the draft of Peace man draft of peace is
tough the draft of peace I
wish I always end up setting fire to
things when I'm make it the draft of
[Music]
Peace like you can actually see it
change Shades
right with each one I think that's it
you guys I actually just noticed
something else
too I felt the controller give a slight
vibration that is
actually it did it it the controller
gives you a slight vibration when you're
supposed to stop
man no
[Music]
way it's harder to do
it we're running out of time though
oh my goodness the subtle cues in this
game that's actually super impressive
man how much they they programmed in
here okay I shouldn't miss any of the
stirring
anymore I shouldn't miss any of
them let's
see oh dude that's
op that's
please don't end it please don't end it
please give it back to me please give it
back to me I can still save
this I was reading
chat no no no we were doing so good man
come on heat it up
quickly better luck next oh that's okay
we know the cheat code now we know the
cheat
code Mr Fluffy what's up welcome
dude you bought a PS2 I'm playing it on
PS3 yeah I'm playing the hard copy
straight off the
PS3 all right we got this the dra of
peace I wish it was he does indeed
Terrell he does indeed say that man
things when I make
[Music]
it see I I still can't get the time
right on the the
pouring but on this one let's see if we
get
it there's the vibration oh my
gosh now this one's a little bit
harder man I feel like I need to go a
lot slower with that than I than I
normally do
oh that was good heyy Dylan thank you
dude gifting out the five
memberships guys if you just got one of
those gifted memberships make sure you
thank our our moderator and regular
Community member Dylan enjoy your access
to all of our Wizarding World themed
emotes you also get access to
our members only videos I need to turn
turn up
the watch out come on come on come on
come on clear it out clear it out clear
it out we can still save this we got a
lot of time we got a lot of
[Music]
time a lot of
time the shaking ones though man the
shaking
ones they tend to mess everything
up yeah Mr Fluffy it's it's random on
YouTube on on the
[Music]
memberships that was
close somebody said how am I streaming
it um just just straight from the PS3
into a a capture card into my
[Music]
computer I stopped that way
early like way earlier than I thought I
should
be all right I think we got it
man yes
sir
boom Tom welcome in
Tom all right let's see who got one of
those gifteds right there Jeffrey wait
dwade we got Dwayne Wade in
here Terell zatana King Tut all got a
gifted membership right there guys
welcome to house rack and tour my
friends courtesy of
Dylan Mr MCD himself okay so wait that
was draft of Peace you guys are just
dropping in um if it's your first time
here you're wondering what the heck is
he doing here we're going for the
platinum trophy man and in order to get
the platinum trophy you have to get Five
Stars Brewing every potion I didn't know
this going in I thought all you had to
do was complete each Potion No no no no
no no no
no so that's what we're going through
and they also don't tell you like it
would be very helpful if instead of just
the number they had like five stars no
so I had to write all of them down the
exact numbers that I need for each one
so we just completed draft of piece now
for Oculus potion our high score is
1705 and we actually need
1843 I know uh who said that M stor yeah
that'd be a nice perk if if YouTube
added
that make it similar to uh to twitch but
then apparently they said twitch is
uh even twitch's CEO said they're not
making
money like what
really you got adds every few minutes in
the Stream
what that it shouldn't be that
many if if if YouTube is to be
believed but they they changed up their
uh YouTube actually gave gave us way
more ad controls
now than we've ever like on live
streams and so it's a little bit
confusing cuz like I just had on this
one there were three settings M so to
hear that you've been getting them a lot
when I picked the lowest one that's it's
kind of
unfortunate all right we've got to make
sure we get all the stirring we got to
get the the great on the stirring each
time come
on oh my goodness it's taking forever to
change there's the vibration all right
unicorn man we have figured out so many
of the little details today some you
guys have have told us and some we've
just figured
out
naturally now see that one I feel like I
stopped right when I felt the
vibration and I still didn't get the
perfect or the great whatever they call
it I don't think that's going to get why
is it doing that watch
out we got to clear out the smoke man
come on get rid of it
probably not going to get it this time
but I guess it's worth it for the
practice just keep
going come
on oh my
goodness yeah that was
[Music]
nuts okay this
one imagine if we can actually save this
no careful soon as we got the smoke I
knew there was no chance ah dang it P
lover thank you for subscribing to the
stream
[Music]
welcome yeah Christian gamer I mean I
guess when The Games first started
coming out streaming wasn't even really
a
thing streaming wasn't even really a
thing back then
all right Let's
do let's try that one
again restores the Drinker sight and
ends the effects of the conjunctivitis
curse conjunctivitis curse it's the
shaking that causes the
problem what like why I don't understand
why we started getting smoke right
there let's just
restart is it because I'm shaking it
over the The
Cauldron maybe that's what restores the
Drinker sight and ends the effect of the
conjunctivitis
curse let's do it over
here there we go all right this one took
forever so I'm just going to try to stir
a lot
faster come on
that's all I can think of Christian
gamer yeah it must just be spilling
some there it
is all right the white one right
here I stopped immediately
dude oh okay that was good yeah yeah
let's do it over here oh not no no no no
no
[Music]
no this one took a while didn't
it okay more
shaking
[Music]
oops are you serious I barely poured
it it's all right we're
[Music]
good yeah trell I don't know if you saw
the the news
but day of said we're getting more what
do they call it updates and features
later this summer so they didn't say a
DLC but I definitely think there's a
chance we
get some pretty fun things this summer
but as far as like a full-on story DLC
Maybe by like the end of the year I mean
I'd love to see it this year but it all
just depends on like what they stop stop
stop depends on like what they kind of
timeline in and if WB said start working
on a sequel right away or if they're
like no let's uh let's put out some DLC
here hold on do we have another
gifted kisi just gifted out five
memberships let's go kesi thank you so
much for gifting those five memberships
out looks like Marcus Brandon Britney
all just got one of those memberships
right there Marco got another one of the
memberships kisi thank you so much
always showing love and support in the
Stream guys if you got one of those
gifteds make sure you think
kisy and
also enjoy your emotes man enjoy using
those emotes in the chat you also get a
little loyalty badge by your name which
I know we need to update to go with the
new
logo and I was ever so short on that one
I don't know if you guys caught
it I was reading out the gifted so I
just kind of ignored that it happened
but we still did not get enough on the
Oculus potion for five
stars restores the Drinker sight so back
we go of the back we go also for any of
you who just uh got gifted a member know
that you also now have access to our
members only behind the scenes videos
you
can find them right here on YouTube and
now that you're a member you'll just uh
automatically be able to see them oh
yeah this one took forever all right
let's go fast go fast our goal this time
is is we don't want to have any smoke
cuz when you have the smoke that like
messes up your
streak okay this one right here like
this one's just a
barely
woo that was that was nice we we haven't
gotten a great on that
before all right let's hold it over
here
oh come on no like why because we got to
shake it up again
right that is so ridiculous man just
restart it just restart
it watch
out wait what is that little Emoji right
there like a little blue person with
stars and
welcome
in well so meore yeah we that that's
that's true Haunted Hogs meet is coming
to other
platforms but
also they said um updates and features
as well so it's like we're getting that
plus Resto the Drinker s whatever the
updates and features are itis
curse oh my goodness you guys so if
you're just tuning in we're trying to
get five stars on all these potions and
they're being a bit of a pain all right
this one we just got to go crazy stir
really
fast game over I like
that all right almost there right
there I like that one
kisi
nice we got a great on that
again oh we got a gr on that okay stay
way over
here I'll take it not a great but oh
[Music]
well
hello
the controller vibration just is it's
kind of op it's like in the dueling when
we figured out you can just stand right
in front of them after you get them down
thanks to Christian gamer tip o just a
little just a little splash right
there just a little splash as my wife
likes to say when she's doing doing
ingredients and cooking just just a
little SP
spash sometimes all you need is that
little splash right
[Music]
there all right getting
close wait for the
vibration come
on there it is all right heat it up heat
it up heat it
up oh that was close we almost went too
long on that
one
let's go Kaylee welcome
in it's going after that five star right
there I would say it's going well it's
it is taking much longer than I thought
which you guys know if you've been
watching the stream I thought we were
going to be able to finish last
Stream So then when I went live today
I'm like okay this is it we went live
about 12:30 so we've only been going 3
hours just 3 hours that's not bad
actually that's not too bad so we
finished the dueling that actually went
much faster than I thought we knocked
that out really quick and then we
started doing some Crest collecting and
I realized yeah that one's going to take
a while that one's going to take a while
so we did a little bit of Crest
collecting now we came over to uh we're
trying to Five Star every
potion and we're making pretty good
progress it was kind of confusing at
first because we didn't didn't know
exactly what what calculated into how
you brew the potions perfectly oh we're
at the final page you guys all right
we're at the final page and we've
already done poly juu we have enough on
that one so we need the
Elixir Love Potion antidote fertilizer
and stamina we've already done poly
juice and we've already done Wigan weld
on this page so we're down to four
potions
here yes Britney I think it was kisi who
who got you uh the GI membership
there all right so on this one we need
2193 can induce excessive singing and
nose tweaking if you don't bro this game
man this game is moving up my rankings
you
guys it it might overtake Chamber of
Secrets like why doesn't this game get
more love from Potter
fans like
[Music]
these these mini games are they're
actually
great and I do not like I don't usually
enjoy the whole mini game
thing oh this one should change quick
right wait for the vibration there it is
stop okay we got a bunch of heating
coming
[Music]
up I went a little bit too long on that
one all right this guy right here
[Music]
oh okay these things as long as we don't
miss which I have done plenty of
[Music]
times we got to do seven of them
all right as long as you don't miss on
those
ingredients they're pretty
easy to get the great
score I mean what I'm so impressed by is
like the level of nuance
here it was kind of annoying at first
but it's a really deep system and it
works that's the thing
like when you're not doing something
right you get punished for it and at
first you're not clear Why seven Great
come on come on come on up the score up
the score 15
chain five stars complete the Elixir is
done love antidote fertilizer and
stamina coming
up maybe it was short quickly that could
be that could be what it was m store but
I like I mean obviously you guys know
I'm a huge Potter fan and I I guess I
just didn't enjoy Order of the Phoenix
when I was a kid that I was like I'm not
even going to bother playing that one I
don't know man maybe I was in let's see
this was PS3 so I would have been either
in high school or
college I would have probably been in
college when this came
out just in case I get any more
chocolate Okay 20 6 29 all right don't
miss
one okay easy easy
easy I did that earlier GG
I had one explode on
[Music]
me cter oil at least it doesn't smell as
bad as it
tastes oh no what
careful I don't understand what we did
wrong did it did the bubbles already run
out
let's save it come on come on come
on if this one doesn't change quick and
we we've lost oh not to worry you can
right there man all right I'm going
right in to try
again ah Love Potion antidote just in
case I get any more
[Music]
chocolates I know I'm going a little bit
faster on that
[Music]
one I just want to see if I can
uh there it
[Music]
is okay
this one right
here like I feel like you should at
least get a good 10 seconds once it
starts
bubbling man they make you move
quick all right this
[Music]
guy
that's so huge right
[Music]
there nice
man and we got a bunch of stirring ones
coming
up hey
JayZ it has been a while what's up
welcome
[Music]
welcome hey you you don't know you
missed most of it you don't know you
don't you got no idea how long we're
going we're determined to get this
platinum trophy today
and I like the crest collecting it may
be too boring for for you guys to sit
and watch honestly honestly it's a
Friday night
man it's a Friday night you guys really
want to just watch me collect these
[Music]
crests this is like this is fun to watch
I feel like but the crest collecting I
can see that getting kind of boring all
right that's got to be five stars man 14
great oh yeah oh yeah yeah yeah
yeah all right down to two potions you
guys
and I think they're two of the harder
ones I remember fertilizer being really
annoying We need oh actually we're
really close on fertilizer we just need
3230 no not
[Music]
you want to see you get the Platinum I
know we're so we're so close and yet so
far fact that the crests are keeping
us okay wait for
it there it
is all right three of these
guys oh almost went too
far oh great everybody's favorite one
the
shake
[Music]
man time's already pretty
low come on we're doing so well actually
I don't want to lose on
time oh
[Music]
no come on heat it heat it heat it heat
it heat it heat it heat
it
again uh that shaking one's going to
cause US
problems come on come on save
this stirring stirring just takes
forever no change color
[Music]
please oh we still got a lot of
ingredients to go
man no not
you
[Music]
I don't think we've gotten enough
greates to be honest with you I've just
been trying to
survive just been trying to
survive yep we didn't get a great on
that one
either we did on that one though okay
wait where's the rat there he
[Music]
is okay we got to get all three of these
come
on nice now we just stir only question
is if we got enough for the five
star
come on it's not changing
color I don't like
this oh my gosh we're going to lose
it
is
I'm so annoyed right
now I'm so
[Music]
annoyed got to take a bite of a banana
after that
dude I'm about to do stamina just
because I don't want to have
to now let's do fertilizer while it's
still fresh in my
[Music]
mind
the stirring is just was wrecking us on
that
[Music]
one
what yes Kaylee yes we do looks like
Jenny got it posted there or
Dylan thank you
guys come
on
no there we go all right 64 seconds
at least we have plenty of
time oh no I knew that was going to
happen like when you stop pouring it's
like it wears
off oh that's going to ruin it for
us dude it takes
[Music]
forever
can we save
it all right we're decent on time as
long as we don't have any other
[Music]
mistakes hey no worries Jay-Z Thank you
for stopping by hope you have a great
rest of your
day why is this not shaking oh we don't
have to shake it what am I
[Music]
doing the rat where's the rat he's in
the
back
[Music]
all right come on
man so much time on this
one and I make a stupid silly mistake
like
that all right let's see let's see let's
see come
on if 65 seconds isn't enough from here
then this is the most ridiculous potion
in the
game all right finally getting some
change there we go now is it enough
though no oh thank
goodness I did not want to do that one
again oh man all right
fertilizer complete now we need
stamina stamina game
all right guys let's do this first try
pumpkin
juice first try first try first
try oh come
on haven't gotten any great so
far okay this should be an easy one
all right now we need to get one on
stirring
[Music]
nice that's
great
give me some of that
dung hope you're wearing gloves
Harry or you think they just like I
guess they could use their
wand although we do see them in the
movies and stuff they actually pick up
the vials and the beakers and
flasks why is this taking so
long
[Music]
all right more pumpkin juice if I
remember right this one had a ton of
ingredients salamander blood salamander
blood in the
world all right five of these
guys
[Music]
excellent come
on
all
right got to be getting close to the end
surely oh here we go again only 30
seconds left on this it's not changing
color no we need darker darker darker
darker all right almost to Orange
bro this is going to rub the padding off
my
controller that was
nuts oh my gosh oh
[Music]
my
well it's an interesting it's the
stirring man why don't you try again the
stirring is so
ridiculous not even going to not even
going to wallow in pity we're going
right back
in right back in right back
[Music]
in
all right I'm not playing around on the
stirring ones
like I think I'm going to use I think my
left thumb goes faster when I like reach
[Music]
over stop nice
there we go all right this is the one
that went
insane oh my goodness man okay okay okay
okay yeah Christian Gamers got the Str
[Music]
all right if I remember right we're
probably around half halfway
through I know I can feel the
tension the tension
mounting come on
bubbles I love the little
uh container that the pumpkin juice or
not the pumpkin juice the actually what
is the pumpkin juice is at the top
what is that one in the middle right
there with the Hog on it some kind of
syrup all right we got to go faster come
on 95 seconds but
still come on come on Harry stir that
potion young
man all right we're getting a change
we're kind of red red all right orange
is next there it is okay
okay this is the one where we messed up
last time but now we have 93 seconds to
work
with excuse me oh my gosh
imagine imagine if
[Music]
we
not the best coloration on that
one trying to get a
perfect all right take our time take our
time
get get the
bubble oh I hope we got it man I do not
want to do that
again only
nine
oh
potions
complete all right if my calculations
are right that should be it I don't see
the badge
though there it
is woo man
oh my gosh we got it there it is Master
potioneer
potions officially complete Twisted girl
welcome in no that was the gosh what was
that on that was just the second time I
think on
stamina fertilizer took us like
three all
right
so dueling is
complete potions are
complete and flying is complete which
means the only thing we still lack for
the platinum trophy are a whole lot of
Crest I shouldn't say a whole lot the
the mini ones guys that's just insane
that that's Insanity that's Insanity
Christian gamer already looked it up for
us and so if you guys see in the bottom
left corner there see how we have 15 out
of 25 but then in the parentheses
68008 so 68008 is our total number of
mini crests that we've collected the
whole game the whole game throughout the
story throughout all the extra stuff
we've been that's that's the
number wait wait wait wait wait
wait I like I don't have a zoomed in cam
but I need I need to zoom this in right
now we need
25,000
25 z00 Z
25,000 we have 6,8 8008 I just want to
make sure you guys I just want to make
sure you guys heard it heard it
clear I
just just want to make
sure the the larger ones I don't feel
like are going to be as big of a problem
we only need 20 three of
those so I'm counting on you guys to
keep me company here man keep me company
keep things oh my goodness where is she
going whoa whoa whoa whoa slow down
people slow
down it's like an emergency in the
herbology greenhouse what is happening
all right training
ground yeah this is where I want to be
outside
okay I've gotten several crests over in
that
area but it doesn't hurt to just double
check doesn't hurt to double check we
got that one
already uh I wonder if we can go in
here
H I like I 25,000 you guys that's
Insanity I'm totally down to go for the
23 on stream but 25,000 man I think
we'll have to do that off
stream oh wait that's back herbology I
don't want to go back
there okay that's good GG I'll be here
for as long as it takes appreciate the
support guys I need I need the moral
support for
sure lend me your strength people oh
here we go let's go incendio all right
23 knock it down to
22 I I mean is is literally just going
to be you spam running around the whole
entire School
spamming this on the right analog stick
over and over and over and over and
over just just over and over that's
it that's
it oh my goodness
man oh by the way yeah yes thank you uh
Jenny for welcoming Noah I missed that
one Noah thank you for subscribing to
the channel appreciate it actually you
know what let me check here let me check
something we might see what we're at
man
59,92876 we do Wizarding World content
here make sure you subscribe it's free
it's easy to do you just click a little
button and you're going to help us get
one step closer to 60,000 subscribers
here on
YouTube all
right hi
Harry all right what is that now
21 yeah I didn't think we'd explored
this
area oh nice lots of Minis lots of
minis give me all the
minis oh yeah I need to go to the boat
house you guys were saying the
uh I think you're right cuz I don't
think I've done any of
those all right Nick lead lead the way
dude 32 more that's right let's
go just subscribed yesterday Danny Danny
Stormborn love the name by the
way I've never made any content about
Game of Thrones but big big Game of
Thrones fan as well appreciate you
subscribing oh yeah he's taking us back
out into the training ground all right
Nick let's put on the fullon Sprint
here as he takes places spam the mini
Crest button
okay it's not working there it
goes oh come on if you run into
anything okay wait so you guys were
saying like incendio on
these would you like to stop and get
that let's
go yes I would Nick I I would very much
like to
stop can you see the membership videos
Marco oh so if you go to
uh actually does you does YouTube have
uh Dylan if you're still here you'd
probably know does it have a I don't
think it has like a specific section but
if you just go to our main page and then
hit videos scroll through and look for
any that just have like me with no with
basically no thumbnail it's just like me
uh and I usually put it in the title of
the video too but I feel like they
should have a a section somewhere where
you can
see there is a member okay good good
good I was hoping so that'd be kind of
strange if they didn't have
that so yeah Dylan said there's like a
specific membership section that you
should be able to
see silver Legion a wizard is never late
no worries no worries thank you for
stopping by boiled beetles boil boiled
boiled
yes they'd like that wouldn't they all
right just open up man thank
you all right
so we need
more 20 more let's go all right 20 more
of the of the big crests and I didn't
even know I needed to be on the lookout
for the you're right Christian gamer man
I just need to get in the habit of just
even when I'm chatting with you guys
just constantly be spam in the right
analog stick to to to get these mini
crests what a horrible trophy like like
what a what an a horrible
collectible I mean that's just like
that's busy work it's just wrong it's
just cruel it's just specifically for
those people like me who they're
like we know there's going to be
somebody out there to go for these
Platinum trophies and we need at least
one trophy there's got to be at least
one that will just drive them absolutely
insane and that's the one they
picked they're like we're going to put
25,000 of these tiny little mini
crests oh but other than that like I
really I really don't have many bad
things to say about this game I'll be
honest with you guys I've enjoyed it far
more than I expected I
would slacks and yeah I I I think it was
a pretty great
game all right so I know we did a lot of
these during the
actual the story Quest so see I don't
see any more you guys I think we may
have gotten them
all I still think it was worth it to
come down to the boat house though like
I know there for sure was one right here
but wasn't that part of the mission bro
stop what the
heck
oh my goodness man I was not ready for
that I just
stopped it's definitely unnecessary busy
work it is man it
is all right oh I think I do see one
right
there
yeah yeah Marco there should be like a
membership Tab and then you should be
able to see the members only videos and
also like sometimes I'll do members only
polls and sometimes members only posts
so like there are certain posts I can
set it to where only members can can see
them
okay here's here's one for sure this
will be
19 the best movie tie in game well Sean
that chamber the the the PS2 GameCube
that version of Chamber of Secrets was I
always said was my favorite oh it broke
okay I didn't realize it
broke and it probably still is
but this one is is really close it's
really close it maybe because I had my
expectations a lot
lower but i' I've really really enjoyed
this game except for this this vetch
Quest except for that everything else
has been great
though I loved all the mini games which
I didn't think I would here we go right
here all right now we need something to
throw up there
is there anything
nearby which one do we need Dylan we
need
uh oh my goodness do we just have three
back to back to back subscribers slaon
marno and twisted girl thank you guys
appreciate the subs welcome
welcome that moves us
even closer to 60k we might be able to
hit it this stream
man plus we also have people you know
who could be
subscribing not watching the live stream
just watching our videos right now no
don't roll down the
hill okay I need to scroll back up and
look at Dylan's post
though Clock Tower Courtyard Hogwarts
grounds on your right just before
entering the Quidditch
cave oh I do remember that one
I don't remember picking it up I do
remember seeing it before I knew that I
needed to shoot those are you serious
come
on don't do this to
me
they're trying to make me
angrier they're trying to make me
angrier they hear me complaining about
the the mini
crests all right let me scoot like back
up a little bit so we can get it up
higher like if if all they had to do man
all they had to do to make this work
they give you like a free aim like when
you hold R2 you can aim
but I can't like shoot it from this from
this spot if they would just let you aim
it would have been it would have been
perfect let me try to get it
closer the graphics probably look like
Hogwarts Legacy on switch they're not
bad are they like for uh for this era of
games yeah we definitely need to be
higher
up
that's a good question what about
chamber beats this one I can tell you
one thing about chamber is it's kind of
the opposite of your question but one
thing about chamber that is definitely
not better is the the loading times the
loading times in chamber of secrets are
horrible but there's just like a certain
charm that I feel like Chamber of
Secrets has I love the art style in
Chamber of Secrets I feel like it was
that style it was like the video games
they had their own unique look for Harry
that I thought were closer to the books
but then they understandably hit a point
where you know the movies were popular
and so they wanted to they had more
graphical capability so they instead of
that more artistic cartoony
style they wanted to make it look more
like the the uh the movies which I
understand but man that that art style
was so good did we just completely lose
it or does surely it
respawns yeah there it is it's back
and also like I love the how the Spells
were worked better then they still
weren't great but like I just hate
having to constantly uh smash the right
stick to do
spells oh I knew that one wasn't going
to hit Sean thank you for subscribing as
well let's go man we might we might hit
the 60k this uh this
stream
all right this has been the one that's I
I haven't taken this long on any of
these this is kind of
crazy I'm going to go back up a little
bit
higher oh yeah that should be like Point
Blank Range
what go ahead and fall off
please why does it
not okay let's let's walk over
here
all right I'm just going to put it right
next to
it how is that not
working oh the bean collecting yes oh
wizard cards
man wizard
cards that's one thing about these like
this game was better for just like the
pure
exploration but the rewards aren't
really that great you know know it's
just like you run around for these
stinking mini
crests I love collecting the wizard
cards like I realize it's a it's a
product product of its time right you
know there's only so much but like how
Hogwarts Legacy has the little
uh the AO pages and
the come on dude this is
crazy no M stor you would think you
could right but apparently these
little whatever those little platforms
are frames that they're attached
to they're too
strong for AO and Wingardium Leviosa
yeah Marcus I think I think you're right
dude I think we might need to try a
different
Strat oh my goodness Marco with the
Super
Chat dude Marco way too kind of you my
friend appreciate you dropping in with
the Super Chat the
59.99 of a currency I'm not familiar
with that's celebrate their first Super
that's your first ever Super Chat dude
thank you so much man I really
appreciate the support you guys have
been going crazy with the uh the gifted
memberships today the the new
subscribers I normally don't even stream
on Fridays man maybe you guys maybe you
guys like the the Friday stream
times but thank you marus appreciate it
hope you're having a uh a good
Friday yeah see this one like the
problem is you from down here Marco it
like doesn't or who said that
Marcus oh we got Marco and Marcus in
here throwing me
off it doesn't let you like aim it like
see I can't change the trajectory like
see if I could look up and it would go
that
direction Euros there you go Jenny yeah
yeah yeah
yeah that was like that was 65 $65. 39
in
US appreciate it
Marco right in front of it you think
like right below it
Dylan I I feel like that's the closest
we've gotten
honestly it's just not it needs to
bounce just like a little bit
higher all right let's try three from
right here under it and if if if none of
the three
hit okay that one doesn't whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa that one doesn't
count okay okay that one counts that was
one come on just roll off the
hill right across from it and backed up
all right let's try
that oh if we could stand on top of that
that that actually be perfect all right
so this is as far back as it's going to
let me
go okay like right
here oh that's that's got to be it
though that's got to be it maybe if I
launch it from like right
here nope a little bit closer a little
bit
closer there we
go sheesh man all right I lost count of
where we were at all right 10 eight out
of 125 on the big
crests
shees shout out Christian gamer shout
out Dylan for the strategy right
there congrat or nice job thank you yeah
we F that one took way too
long all right so I think I've already
gotten the ones in this
area oh there we go big time on the
little minis right
there
all right did we miss any in this area I
don't think so I'm just going to run up
here just to double
check but I'm pretty sure we got
everything oh no sir no we did not no we
did
not no we did
not that's why it doesn't hurt to double
check
oh do we have another one no that's just
a little
uh all right we did already get that one
okay all right all right all right let's
go back over now we got to go back down
to the ground level and make sure we
repair that wait where did Nick come
from Luna you just came back in here and
now she wants out look some more of you
guys already know you guys already
know tomorrow she just can't make up her
[Music]
mind nah you got to stay for a minute
now you got to
stay unless mom comes to let you
out
har let's take a peek in
here I don't even know where this leads
man it's kind of crazy to me that we
still
have she's
crazy mom told Luna she's in trouble man
she's in
trouble okay yeah now we're back in the
grand staircase that's what I
thought all right so let's let's see
um Clock Tower
Courtyard
Hospital Wing I haven't been
there all right I want to I want to
stick to outside first
though I want to stick to outside and I
I haven't really looked around Hagrid's
Hut in a while let's go there take us
there Nick find the nearest shortcut my
man
H let's grab these I know it's probably
not even worth turning
around but we're going to need 25,000 of
them if you guys didn't
hear so we just need to constantly be
spamming
it sorry Nick wait for me
dude Oh I thought I finished my banana
let's
go boiled Beatles they say I'm parano
playing Hogwart py while watching this
makes for a pretty good Friday
afternoon Sean is that your first
playthrough or are you
like just going through 100 pering or is
there something like specific you're
working
toward all right so we also need to be
on the
lookout for another one of those I
remember Dylan saying
there near this quidditch
cave there's another box that we need to
explode oh wait was
out thought I saw something out of the
corner of my eye for just a second re
Larry
rello man I wish I had rello in this
game to be honest with
you lots of rello spam but yeah it would
be it would be helpful right
now oh right there that's the one I was
thinking of but that's there it is there
it is there it
is hold on
Nick
[Music]
all right I think that is one one0 okay
15 more 15 more of the big ones you
guys I feel like there's got to be at
least one area that we
just where we haven't really explored
much and we're going to get like 10 of
them in that
area that'd be great wouldn't it
just get lost Potter get lost
Potter have you ever actually
seen all right there used to be one
right there we already got that
one okay I think we got everything up
here you can't go into Hogs meat in this
game can
you oh it's your first playthrough as a
Hufflepuff let's go man
yeah enjoy enjoy that first time
experience
dude and then hopefully this
summer this summer might have a reason
to jump back in although if you're like
me and you want to go uh it's a fun
Platinum it's kind of annoying that you
have to play through all four houses at
least to a
point and a lot of people complain about
the the Merlin
trials but it's it is a fun Platinum I
think I was wondering if we need to
smash
these imagine if there was a Crest
inside one of
them all right so Hagrid's
Hut well what are you guys doing dueling
over here
it's mine I bought loads of chocolate
frogs to get them and I've almost got a
full set looks like you'll be one card
short this week then doesn't it hey why
don't you leave him alone this has got
nothing to do with you Potter why don't
you go and clean your broom or
something oh
no I don't have to worry about any kind
of point system with you
all I'm trying to do is win that's
it thanks Ari she was really mean nice
and it was for a Crest let's
go okay is there anything else down in
this
area this over here
is that really
it I think there are six statue crests I
feel like that's probably only the
second one or so that I've
gotten all right so we already got this
one cuz I don't see anything
there and we cannot go up that hill can
we actually go inside hagrids
you're going to 100% it Sean nice dude
yeah I think it's I think it's pretty
fun one to
do Fang let me in
dude greetings from
Greece let's go welcome in what time is
it over there in
Greece and also what is it it's
probably is it Saturday it's probably
Saturday by now isn't
it or you said Friday evening
so I'm doing well thank you for
asking we are just uh there we go dude
another one all right another mini Crest
on the road to 25,000 mini
crests but we're just breaking it
up oh going to be Saturday very soon
gotcha a pumpkin in the chimney wait
what
what at
hagrids what are you talking about
meor is there a pumpkin up there are you
just saying trying to launch one
in nah I I don't think it's going to
give you
anything if that's one of them that
would be a crazy difficult
challenge crazy
difficult there's there's got to be a
strat for collecting these mini crests
that's what I'm going to do tonight
after stream I'm going to look
up there has to be like a spot where
people Farm
them a spot where you can get them
faster something
dude okay nothing for
that
all right so we're back to the entrance
oh you think I got yeah I do think I got
a Crest there it was somewhere near the
chimney yeah was on like on top of his
house I believe if I remember
right oh my goodness okay well all right
let's think you guys let's think where
oh sorry
Nick I need to do a where is all right
so we we've done astronomy test we've
done charms we've done the boat house
Clock Tower and clock tower
Courtyard well hello there I have not
been to the clock tower in a while I
know there's at least one there that we
didn't get it first but I eventually
went back and got
it so there's a chance that clock tower
is a bust and we don't find anything
there yeah I just I I got to get in the
habit of spamming for the
mini actually not not even getting any
right
now there's a
couple got to run all the way back up to
the
school you guys haven't checked out
today's video yet we posted a video
early this morning on all the Harry
Potter theme park
news so if you are someone who is uh
ever wanted to go to any of the Potter
theme parks or you've enjoyed going to
one of the Potter theme parks check out
that video man because what they have in
store sounds absolutely amazing all
right Nick I'm going to break off from
you for a
second I'm going to break off from you
for just a
moment because I want to thoroughly
check the allery since we're already
here
oh my gosh
yes I agree with you I'm not sure how to
pronounce your name I know you said
you're from Greece my apologies but
I I just finished Order of the Phoenix a
few weeks ago we've got the let's play
up on the
channel and I played that one as a kid
and don't remember enjoying it that much
and when I replayed it I didn't enjoy it
that much but this one I've had a lot
more fun I totally
agree
right Josh yeah or if they had the flu
Flames like they do in Hogwarts Legacy
where we could just jump
around well would you look at
that I'm glad we came up
here Luna's bark whining at the door
again she's she's about to be in so much
trouble
no my wife just been having to come
constantly get up and open the
door I know there's a Crest around here
somewhere yeah I just I just got it Nick
thank
you Nick Nico hey we got another Nico
part of our community here that
works you have
J oh that's huge huge that's huge did
you guys see what that said probably not
because my webcam was blocking part of
it it said you'll now unlock more mini
crests with each
cast hopefully it's
like 10 times what we were earning
before Oh another Crest let's go dude
the allery was a big win man big win big
win at the
allery what is that we had one outside
two inside already make it three inside
the allery let's
go and then we have uh Joey Joey thank
you for subscribing my friend
welcome unable to play this game on
PS5 I don't
don't think so because wait PS5 can't
play can it play PS3 games no PS4 games
right yeah yeah yeah so I'm I'm playing
it on my I still have my PS3 Slim so
that's how I'm playing
it but yeah I don't think you can play
it on a PS5 and they don't have it
available digitally
anywhere as far as PlayStation
goes
all right this was nice this was a good
uh this was a good call to stop by the
allery here hold on is that something
else above
us yeah that's true Nico I don't think
the Potter games are on there
though I don't think the Potter games
are on there cuz I I was looking for
that they only have certain ones
available on
the yeah through like the cloud
streaming and
stuff oh dude look you can actually oh
it's just leaves I thought it was
actually people playing at the quidditch
field that would have been a crazy extra
detail all right so nothing over
here all right Nick appreciate you being
patient and waiting dude let's go
all right so what are we at now 115 all
right let's go man down to
10 and maybe maybe when we unlock oh
dude there's another there's another one
right there did we not get that one
already I thought we got this
one not that I'm
complaining oh wait did we already get
it
oh I think we did cuz the the Crest is
gone isn't
it is that a
Crest no that's a
rock yeah I'm almost pausi if we already
got that
one
okay all right so that's kind of
unfortunate that the little boxes come
back I was hoping hoping they didn't
come back at all cuz that's a little
confusing you're not sure if you've
gotten it yet or not but I think we we
had just gotten that one
earlier
so Josh I'm playing it directly on my my
PS3 and then we're streaming it through
a capture
card
get yeah not an not an emulator or
anything just just the oldfashioned
PlayStation 3 PlayStation 3
slim all right come on give me lots of
lots of mini crests going through here
lots of mini Crest there we oh there we
go there we go there we go
that's
doing our little trick that we learned
from Christian gamer timing it just
right oh that was a good one that was a
good one let's go oh this is huge man
this is
huge hopefully that actually makes a big
difference let's see
7,858 I don't remember what we read just
a moment
ago
everything all right I think I saw yep
there it
is
raparo glad could appreciate it Nick oh
my goodness there's so many
here I can't
believe yeah Josh it was actually the
first Harry Potter game oh I have to
double check on that cuz did this did
the did Lego Harry Potter years one
through four come out before or after
this game I feel like after this game
right I'm pretty sure this is the first
Potter game to ever have PlayStation
trophies um Order of the Phoenix
definitely did not it was one of the
last PS3 games not to have have trophies
cuz Sony eventually they started
requiring it when they first enabled
trophies it it wasn't a
requirement but then they started
requiring that all games have it I was
so disappointed cuz I thought there was
a chance that it would actually have
trophies but nope they were never added
for that
game nio chamber secrets on PC yeah
there was somebody here earlier uh one
of the regulars in our stream
Wario loves that one I've only played a
little bit of chamber on on the PC but
what I what I played I can definitely
see why people like that one a
lot okay this must be another one yeah
yeah yeah they're they're arguing
they're
arguing let me help you out here
guys hey harry hi yeah I heard your
impressing slor with your skill at
potion making any chance you can make
you want to make a potion for me yeah
okay I'll make it for your potions
Club optional
task have you made that volubilis potion
for me not yet sorry I'll try and finish
it dude I've made like 50 of them can't
you just take one that I already
have all right Dylan are you still
here or anybody who knows about the
truck for this
game he he's probably going to give me a
Crest right here isn't
he I bet we have to do
it I bet we have to do it to get to get
a
Crest all right first I'm going to go up
the clock
tower whole community that works on
Chamber of Secrets B fixing bugs dude
that might be the I wish Warrior is
still here Wario was telling me about
some special mod that just get he uses
to play the
game and he was he was telling me how
much he recommends it oh they're having
a battle right here too hold on this is
about to be a
Crest well I want it so give it to me I
once doesn't get in this case I'll think
you'll find it does what's the matter
you're sticking your nose where it's not
welcome that's the matter oh
dang expelling armor
oh no way you dodged
that
what there we
[Music]
go fully charged Stupify right to the
face thanks
Harry wait did the guy I helped just
call me snake no I think I guess he was
calling him
snakehead don't call me snake head dude
come on yes I'm a parcel mouth
but oh there's got to be another one in
here somewhere got to be got to
be Hospital
Wing oh dude there's none in the
hospital
Wing maybe there used to be one and we
already got it I know Jake or Josh that
if you get right up close and you do the
fully charged Stupify it's just massive
damage if you're further away it fires
it in like three bursts they like
separate but when you're up close like
that all three of them hit we figured
that out earlier when we were doing the
dueling Club unintentionally figured
that
out okay I wonder if we probably already
got a Crest right
there $15 for the Wii version that's not
bad at
all yeah Cy I used to to like sell all
my systems when I got a new
one but for some reason I I don't know
why I hung on to the
PS3 that's one that I still have I still
have a Wii as well
okay I'm almost positive we
got dude there's so many mini
crests yeah there used to be one over
there all right we got that one okay so
I guess we just go and
brew a potion for that guy I don't know
why the potions we've already brewed
aren't good enough for
him but apparently he wants a freshly
brewed valous
potion if I would have known that I
would have
waited
wow that girl just like stood her ground
man stood her ground right there giants
I know they're scary but I wish I could
see
one oh wait hold on I got to read K's
comment here and go
back my frog ho away oh wait do you need
help oh this looks like a group that are
fighting we might have to intervene
right here you guys need
anything Tak some responsibility over
security now we have walk
around
wait where is this oh this is back in
the grand staircase okay this a 4 five
all right hold on we don't want
to oh that one was a lot I could hear
it yes give me all the mini
crests
please hi Harry
dude he never can can you not say hi
back Harry come on man all right so kis
he said coming from the clock tower
there was a lion statue on the left for
the hospital
Wing is that the one I got or did I miss
it okay so this is Clock Tower right no
that's a a door we cannot pass
through
see where we're at now
8,492 it is going faster since we got
that upgrade hopefully once we get a few
more all right so this is clock
tower now let's say where is Hospital
Wing which we were just there but I want
to make sure I take the another
adventure Harry oh it was down
downstairs oh yeah this lion statue
right here oh it's got to be these kids
over here I didn't think charms would be
so hard
no no not these kids
all
right so wait isn't that what that means
though kisi that there's some maybe I
already got this one you
think cuz otherwise shouldn't there be
some students in this area
that are having like a little
Coral oh yeah Nico you're you're in good
company here we we are all very excited
most the people part of our Community
here are pretty big Hogwarts Legacy fans
so yeah I'm I I can't wait to see what
they have in
store even if it's just smaller things
you know I'm not expecting like some
massive DLC if it was I would be
absolutely
thrilled but I'm trying to keep my
expectations in check you think I may
have gotten it that's all I can think of
wait were these kids
arguing no all all right okay so let's
go uh let's go brew that potion for that
guy no you're all good I appreciate all
the help I can get on these on the crest
collecting this one's going to take some
time have you seen my chocolate wait it
hopped away no come on nothing nothing
we can interact with on that that one
all
right okay so there's there's the guy
right there that's the guy that wants
the potion dashing Kad pass friend Josh
we were just we were just talking about
that earlier dude I just asked the
stream if they could believe it had been
a
year time flies man time flies
that was such just an unforgettable
ride all the leadup to that game I don't
know if you've been following our
channel for a while Josh but we we
covered that game for years before it
came out did weekly live streams like
breaking down trailers and screenshots
light against
Darkness keep up oh my
goodness we had a lot of fun and so then
when it finally came out it was just it
was just surreal
really H how have we not unlocked
another mini Crest so we've been getting
a
lot my leg's going to sleep
man oh no I lost Nick no there he is he
hold on hold on let me just take a peek
right
here let me just take a little
peek
man I got to give them credit they did a
great job with Hogwarts in these old
games oh here's one I bet if you see the
crest kisi you think that means that we
haven't gotten
it like see how that you see the hard
Crest right there but there's nobody in
here there's nobody in this Hall except
you I talk to you guys no Dum doesn't
seem to be around much this year
oh um I don't know how to break it to
him Temple door doesn't seem to be
around much this year I don't know if he
if he knows yet if he knows what happen
we arrived I'm going to try let's try
this I'm almost paus that we got it in
this
Hall yeah so why would it be showing the
crest right
there yeah that's right fellow
kisi I forgot about about that Danny too
funny you've been falling for a while
nice appreciate it Josh yeah like last
year I don't know kind of the second
half of the year we were sort
of trying to figure out where does our
content go from here man I tried doing
other games which I think I probably
could do other games if I really stuck
to it but then I started just thinking
man there's so much Wizarding World
News even outside of the game so much
Wizarding World News going on especially
with the TV show in the works the new
theme park that's coming plus we've got
quiddit Champions they they're hinting
kind of strongly that there's going to
be a Potter MMO I'm like you know what
man we just need to stick with stick
with Wizarding
World keep you guys informed on
everything happening Lous potion is one
of my favorites I really don't
understand why I have to brew this trick
on others to change their we've made
like 50 potions to me at least this
one's pretty it's
[Music]
easy arsonic thank you for subscribing
welcome
in there's the green I don't have to
worry about score all we have to do is
complete
it it doesn't have to be a high quality
valous potion for for this
guy we just want him to give us a Crest
that's
it arsic there's already a Wizarding
World theme park a couple of them
actually uh in Orlando Florida I'm not
sure where you live in the world but in
Orlando
Florida there are actually like two
Harry Potter theme parks there and then
there's also a smaller one in
La what oh
jeez but um so the one I've been to both
of them my favorite one is oh wait I
wasn't supposed to shake
it my favorite is the one in Orlando
because it's it has both Hogs me and
dgon
Alley it's just a lot bigger there's a
lot more there and so now Universal
Studios just
announced this week actually that
they're opening a third theme park oh
you live in Australia gotcha well if you
ever come this way dude they are they
are absolutely
epic but yeah so at the one in Orlando
they're opening a third part called epic
universe and that one's going to have
the ministry of
magic it just sounds
phenomenal oh Japan that's right Amelia
yes
yes all right so we we brewed that
potion now let's take it back
okay so hold on we need to
do he was in the clock tower wasn't he
having fun are we good good all right
Nick fastest route I don't know if we
have to be fast wait this is the way to
the clock
tower what we just okay whatever I'm
trusting you Nick I'm trusting you in
your abilities and your knowledge of the
school and the the
grounds you better not be leading me
astray
here come on come on Nick oh back in
through this
way imagine if imagine if we take it to
this guy and he's like sorry that's not
good enough I need a five star
potion that be so
annoyed dude my camera is like I can't
believe I've been going all day with it
like
this it is not centered
properly wait hold on zoom
out I don't know how this happened but
it's like it zoomed out a little
bit
also one in
Beijing
what I mean it is a worldwide
phenomenon yeah Michael uh thank you
yeah I I grabbed that one
earlier so I don't know what they it
looks like they pop back up even after
you get
them but yeah we got that little box
when we first went out there dude Nick
this is not the fastest way
oh and then this portrait is going to
put us right in there but still I don't
I don't think this was the fastest path
Nick KAG oh we zadag
dashing yeah I've heard the London
Studio Tour is really good too here we
are all right this dude here you go man
hello here's that valilis potion you
wanted wait a second thanks har okay
never
mind
boom all right all right we are getting
ever closer ladies and gentlemen six we
have six of the large
crests oh my
goodness six of the large
Crest ready to go left to go I'm
sorry okay let's take a look at the full
breakdown
here
all right we've checked astronomy Tower
we've checked boat house we checked
charms Clock Tower Clock Tower
Courtyard I I'll walk around there
before we before we leave this
Dumbledore's
office let me check the courtyard here
really quick we definitely got the box
right
there man we really do need some rello
now
rellia would be
nice yeah it was funny cheses I was
planning to post a lot more I mean I may
at some point post a lot more to that
channel but things have been so crazy so
busy here on the main Channel that I
haven't
even haven't had a
chance to play a lot of games
honestly
oh oh oh hello
hello hey Nico appreciate you stopping
in have a great rest of your evening I
guess for
you it's pretty much evening for me now
too show you the spell list oh for this
game here's what you you only have three
for charms you get these three oh you
can't can't see them all it's Wingardium
Leviosa reparo and
incendio then for dueling you get
Stupify Prego expell armis and then
these three petrificus totalis levoc
Corpus and then charging it's not really
its own spell
but
okay where'd you go Nick right
here yeah I definitely we arrived I
definitely don't
remember
can I not go back
in wait how do we get
this oh can you not go back into
Dumbledore's
office I feel like it should be like a
portrait and you should like have to say
something right nothing's happening
though when I do
it maybe a
spell no okay that's kind of strange
that it still shows up
here okay so Griffin door common room we
checked that
thoroughly entrance courtyard entrance
dungeon we did Hagrid's Hut we did the
Great Hall we did herbology we did
Hospital
Wing we did Library we did allery we did
potions we were in the paved Courtyard
ooh the Quidditch
gate it's just it's going to be like
these random ones isn't
it we've done a lot in Transfiguration
we've done a lot on the training
ground oh man those of you who've been
here for a while in the Stream what do
you
think the entrance hall we were just
there I mean this is the entrance
Courtyard isn't it having fun are we
good
good I think this is
it well here we are yeah that's what I
thought oh my goodness that was a hey
there we go finally we got another one
from the mini
crests what do you want poter okay
let's okay I know we've done that one
over
there hi
Harry yeah we got the let's play Channel
too Josh
yeah we got the let's play Channel and
then we've got the trophy hunting
channel which I may should have just
made those the same channel
but hi Harry hi Harry they're still
small enough that it it would be it'd be
easy to make changes if I if I needed to
quite a few in the astronomy Tower
really okay cuz I went through the
astronomy Tower and didn't find many at
all so maybe I wasn't looking in the
right
spot
just go through
here see where this opens up wait what
is this the viaduct entrance okay ooh
all right did I get this one does he
have
one you guys
arguing no
anybody arguing looking for anyone
arguing I know he he never I'm like why
can't you just say hello say something
back Harry say
something oh we were just in
here I'm just I'm I'm just continuing
with it because we're running into so
many mini crests right
now Transfiguration Courtyard oh my
goodness we've spent so much time here
I'm not even going back out
there oh perfect that was a
lot come on tell me we're at least past
10,000
still
not the viaduct
entrance yeah just I'm hoping I already
got this one
Whatever whatever you needed to
do let's try astronomy Tower again off
on another adventure
Harry
cuz I maybe I just didn't look around
enough I thought it was odd that I
didn't find any there me to behind my
ear poliy but it's also possible that
I it's also possible we found them all
like our first time up there whenever it
was go
away libr liberate stud hey Arvin thank
you for stopping by have a good
one have a good one yeah I'm committed
to getting this Platinum maybe not on
the stream definitely not on the stream
today there's no way we're going to get
all the mini crests unless we find like
some big secret where there's like a
room full of mini
crests boiled beetles boiled boiled
boiled yes they'd like that wouldn't
they
guys if you're just tuning in man we
need six
more of the large
crests six more you know what I'm going
to double check out over
here actually Nick let's let's call an
audible here here let's call an audible
I want to
look where's The Flying
Club take me to the Quidditch gate Nick
is that where we're at right
here okay
so this is as far as you can
actually darn it that's what I was
thinking Joe what's up dude welcome in
Joe Mack
everybody where
is oh my gosh you guys we're at four and
a half hours on this
stream four and a half hours on the in
impromptu stream the allery had a bunch
we were surprised with that one okay
where were we trying to go
to astronomy Tower ly said coming from
the training grounds as you
enter as you enter on the left wall down
the quarter go to the left circular
stairs behind a statue there all right
okay yeah so we're at the training
ground this is good my mom wants me to
go home oh
yes party we
poter yeah this one right here I'm
pretty sure we've already gotten that
one but let's do it again what if it
gave you an extra
one yeah we already got that one
okay oh wait to the left of that that
gate where we were just at back
here
I didn't think charms would be so
hard
okay so wait you're talking about in
here go up the stairs in
here to the left of the gate on the wall
oh wait you probably mean when I first
come out of the that
area MDS squid thank you for Subs
subscribing to the channel I don't think
you mean in
here yeah ultimate James it is pretty
cool to see some of the spots that you
know you know from the
movie ruy we did we did go back to like
you talking about like when you first
start walking toward Hogwarts yeah we
went back there
earlier kind of like near near Hagrid's
Hut and all
that we did that
one all right I think this is what kis
is talking about over
here in this area
maybe yeah we got that one M
store six more crests remaining you guys
guys so there's only I mean just a
handful I don't think I understand what
kisi was
saying okay I'm just going to go to the
astronomy
Tower and see if I can find it from
there I'm
late oh hold on that was that was too
many mini crests for me to pass
up now there is one of those little hogs
out
here is there anybody fighting that we
can have you tried out the jeweling club
yet no not you guys okay all right that
little box over there we already got I'm
pretty sure we already got the ones that
were over
there all right Nick keep leading the
way see that one right there we must
have already gotten this one with that
guy that
statue okay hold on let's
just look around thoroughly in
here there's only six more left man do
you think you
give all right M stor tell them tell
them you guys haven't seen what we had
to do for that
trophy okay okay oh I bet behind this
statue I feel like I got this one yeah
yeah I feel like I remember getting that
one but that still doesn't mean that I
got the rest
so just going to finish running down
this
Hall all right there's the suspension
bridge we got the one that was up
there now see there's
a no oh right here these girls these
girls these girls okay dude I'm
convinced when you see the crest give it
to me I think that means there's
something you have to do one two three
now let's see if it goes away mean even
let's see if it goes away after this the
Sorting Hat stinks and so do
you jeez the Sorting Hat sinks and so do
you super no way you dodg
that oh come on Harry
stop the Sorting Hat stinks and so do
you I feel like I need to make that like
my Twitter bio or
something around okay wait let's see if
it disappears now it does
disappear all right so we got to
remember guys anytime we see a
statue if it has the
crest even if it's just like the
statue that means that there is a way to
turn it into a real
Statue o I don't think I went through
this area in a while
right there see yes yes yes yes yes I
knew there was a
spot I agree with
you did they wait I got to go back and
read what did they just
say somebody just say eat
Hagrid what
all right see who is it man who is it
there's got to be something that we do
in this little
area to unlock that Crest hi
Harry
oh man what is
it oh now we're back in the charms area
yeah I remember
this
har ah raple
H sorry man we've been going like almost
hours I just have to do what I can to
stay
engaged Joe how's your day gone so far
man okay we've already looked in this
area okay that leads up to the astronomy
Tower right there okay we'll be right
back you're going to watch next quid
wait these two looked like they were
fighting kind
of chuckle Brothers I feel like you're
like setting me up for a joke or
something
all right it was back where was that we
already we already lost
it where was that little uh that statue
with the crest
man no way we lost it
already no way did
he oh it was this hallway wasn't
it
no dude I'm so turned
around okay that opens back out to the
training ground which is how we started
this whole thing this is where we came
in all right it's probably good to just
start over again from
here
man
okay so they're not fighting they always
look these two look like they're about
to have some kind of
duel but yeah I can't oh wait these two
these two these
two no they're talking about wizard
chess and then this leads to the
suspension
bridge that one the Crest is gone we got
that one all
right we're going to get to the bottom
of this guys don't worry
do I believe in aliens though chuckle
Brothers said they're being serious just
curious I mean it's one of those weird
things right like people always site
statistical probability and it's like
surely there they're like
mathematically it would almost have to
be the case
and
yet we still can't find anything it's so
strange I mean I feel like when I was a
kid like if you would said you even
thought about if you even considered
aliens were real people would just laugh
now if you say no people would laugh at
you for that I so I feel like it's like
it keeps it keeps
changing I will say if they were like if
if they were really like highly Advanced
I think they would have already found us
by
now or or it could be like they realized
dude that is an in an insane place we
want to do everything we possibly can
for those people to never find
us no I think if we ever did it would be
like something really
like just like really primitive like
something small like
microscopic they might not want to be
found right exactly especially if they
had any kind of insight into
humans be like dude those people crazy
man those people crazy keep them far
away guys I I don't know how I have I
have gotten so turned
around how did I I still haven't found
the hallway where we saw the
crest
so I still haven't found
it I guess the good news is like we're
having to do these uh like we need these
mini crests
anyway have no chance okay Nick take me
back to astronomy
Tower are you to know we need your help
Nick I'm not a good
Navigator not a good Navigator trying to
find all the shards and Dragon Age
Inquisition is it pretty pretty rough I
mean we are we're five away on the big
crests the mini Crest at least as as
tedious and annoying as it's going to be
at least you don't have to just search
in vain right you don't have to search
in vain and just be totally confused you
know exactly what to
do the big Crest though we're just at
the mercy
of stumbling into the right room which I
got to say man I know I mentioned it
once already but they really did do a
good job with Hogwarts in this game and
the fact that you can run through all of
this with next to no loading wait did he
just go hold on he did go in
here I mean the loading is practically
non-existent
wait it's gone
now okay hold on I I don't want to get
sidetracked again I'm getting
sidetracked I'm getting I'm getting
sidetracked all right Nick wait one
second dude one second one second all
right all I got to do is go back to the
okay and
this okay I don't know where we at man I
don't know this is the charms area is
this charms right here okay yes all
right hello har okay Nick sorry man
sorry Nick we're we're just we're
checking everywhere for these
crests leave no stone unturned have you
seen my chocolate
frog all right here we are man all right
so kesi said earlier that there were
like probably six or something in here
so we definitely found the one there's
one that you're like required to find
it's like when you come right through
here wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait
wait okay we're back we found it we
found it we found it all right this lion
he has a Crest a and so far I mean it
seems to be whenever they're holding a
Crest there's something you need to do
in the
area to unlock
it so far it has been someone either
a
oh I didn't know other people around
here could do
magic are you kidding
me all right maybe it's something with
the
statues no not that
statue it's almost always something with
a student
like hi are what you guys this is so
confusing I do remember that M store
somebody talking about chocolate frog
but I couldn't I couldn't talk or
interact with them
he's trying to get
byad oh dude all right
well hey
hurry yes can I can we speak to them
Harry no you can't all right
fine okay let's go back up into the
astronomy Tower
see that one has does have like a slight
loading right there but it's not bad at
allice okay astronomy
Tower see you can't go in this door can
you that's from the lion statue okay
wait wait wait that's so that's to
unlock the
one the lion statue oh okay let's go
hold on I'm just going to double check
up here one more
time oh man imagine if there was one
just like right under there hiding this
whole
time okay okay so let's before I get
sidetracked again let's follow K's
instructions here right
away let's go straight
back see if I can actually find my way
back to the
Statue Spirit of King and
lunga lunga sorry if I'm mispronouncing
that but welcome thank you guys for
subscribing to the channel
here all right so kisi
set we're gonna go back to the lion
statue right
here all right around the corner
straight ahead and up the
steps okay wait so which corner probably
if you're walking in from this way all
right so here we go around the
corner straight
ahead up the steps past the gate all
right we're on the right track
here 125 turn
around
left of the gate on the wall okay that
one that one right there yeah we got
that one so that one we can we can check
off we found that
one what I'm so confused by is that one
that's actually showing a
Crest typically when you see the
statues and they have the
crest there's something for you to do in
the
area
are you going to visit
H like somebody
arguing all right I'm just going to go
back in
here this is crazy man this is crazy Mr
Ren what's up Ren happy Friday
indeed hey there's another
Crest okay now we're back in the charms
area right right right right right
right Ren this this Platinum trophy is
uh It's a Grind we're trying to find all
the crests in the
game oh that one's got a Crest
too you guys they're just trolling me at
this point they're trolling
me hi Harry hi can you help me make a
guarding potion please I've tried making
it loads of times and is just not
working yeah all right I can make it a
potion no we've already made
them okay so hers is definitely going to
appear right
there oh giring potion giring potion
giring potion having fun are we good
good happy headlines you sell more
newspapers and free gifts you
do Ren have you ever played this one the
game is the game is actually really good
like I'm I've been really impressed with
the game and the trophies aren't bad
except for this one this one has been
the biggest Thorn In My Side by
far okay that girl was in the library
right light against
Darkness so it's got it's got to be like
that man there's got to be a student in
there that we can talk to Darkness and a
good morning to you
Harry
all right Nick come on dude we're not
messing
around take us there
quickly oh sorry Nick let me grab these
afternoon
yeah oh my gosh there's another
one you guys that means there's there's
three three though there's three that we
know about that's that's kind of a good
sign if if I'm correct that means three
of the
five we know the position hey
Harry can I not talk to you
guys dude what is it about these where
there's nobody to talk
to no way kisi that's crazy but that
makes sense too
like oh my gosh you guys have fun now
all right ging
potion dude I hope a lot of them aren't
potion
ones like it's not bad Brewing the
potion you just have to keep coming back
here who wants to keep doing
that not
meing oh good this one's easy this one's
easy
smelly nope not
[Music]
you okay one of
these I just can't believe we're having
to brew potions
again I thought we were done with
Brewing the
potions we had to through so many of
them man replay squad's going to be like
excuse me a 5H hour
stream we're getting close actually
we're about to hit five the 5 hour
[Music]
mark Dylan how many of them would you
say are potion brewing
versus
duels I'd so much rather do the
[Music]
duels
well this is this is I guess this is a
good sign cuz we know for sure where
three three are we just like they're
right in this immediate area okay we
just brewed a giring
potion all right now we need Nick to
take us to the
library having fun are we good good why
does it show you're not a member say
what
I'm not sure Ren maybe it just like uh
ran
out it could have like just
expired it is the first of the month I'm
not sure when you had when you initi I
guess it's based on when you initially
became a
member okay
so we probably have to finish this one
before that that one will appear oh
sorry Nick I didn't think you went in
there Nick where'd you go
dude so much backtracking we need the
Hogwarts Legacy flu
Flames to be young
again light against
Darkness pass friend I must change that
password hope you guys are all having
having a awesome Friday so
far appreciate you spending some time
here hanging
out hope you guys are getting ready for
a fun relaxing
weekend I don't know about you guys man
this is a sign of my age the older I get
it's like the relaxing weekends are the
best if you
Voldemort dude that portrait not afraid
to speak his name okay all right all
right right oh you should have it set up
to automatic renewal you're here I don't
know dude that's
weird could just be a visual glitch okay
where was that
girl wait it was you wasn't it wait
wait where'd she
go you here you are hello again I made
you the guarding po yes thank you thank
you thank you that's
brilliant Princess Bubblegum love that
name thank you for
subscribing five total duels and five
total potions okay so I think we've done
oh my gosh the rest are going to be
potions man I've only I only remember
two
potions and the fact that you have to do
them in order that's constant
backtracking okay well here's something
we can check right away we know where
two locations are happy headlines will
be if you beat Voldemort hey we know
where where two
locations
are all right so let me ask Nick to take
me back to
herbology and we'll check that one King
Tut you got a DND D campaign let's
go and you're the you're dming it too
nice RM thank you for
subscribing
these portraits take forever to open up
too against
Darkness keep up the good oh my neck
man I fell asleep on the couch last
night and my neck is
just crying out in pain at me for doing
that all right it was it was this one
here and there's a new guy man there's a
new
guy what kind of potion do you want bro
go ahead hiav hey any chance you can
help me make an antidote to Common
poisons sure I can make it at potions
these freaking potions dude have you got
the antidot only Louise has been asking
me for it okay I'll bring it to you see
that that
is hello Harry have you got the antidote
only that is annoying man that even if
if you've already brewed one hello har
oh I did not mean to talk to him again I
promise only L has been it's like it
should stay in your inventory see you
later so then if I've already brw it I
can just be like oh sure man here you go
your at your chosen destination oh
jeez all right I'm almost positive this
will be the the third potion we've done
right and then we know where one more is
so then finding that last one all right
so he wanted the
antidote ah always useful to have
brother tyly if you know you'll be
mixing some poisonous
ingredients okay
bizor
[Music]
oh I almost went too far on that
one oh great our favorite the one we got
to shake
up
mistl toe berries hopefully nargle
free hopefully nargle
free each potion type you think so
Magicka I could see that which means the
next two are going to be
[Music]
harder
it's these that take so long
man I mean this is taking
forever this is when I have to remind
myself I'm doing something that is
optional I'm not required to do all
these extra side quests that I'm
doing I am choosing
this no not
[Music]
you oh no way that
missed
no way okay now I'm
just Vault boy Steve the potion making
is really
good way better than I was expecting
this is my first time ever playing the
game this this series that we've been
[Music]
doing all right let's let's take his
potion
[Music]
back he was just like right outside here
wasn't
he look at that and another five star
too and another five
star I can't believe they make that's
such a weird thing even though I've
brewed every single potion some of them
multiple times whenever somebody asks
for one here he's like oh man I don't
have one
actually I think he was in here wasn't
he there he is okay then we need to set
our course for the astronomy Tower
here's that antidote oh brilliant Louise
is going to be pleased bet you go on a
date with me
now oh man this game's funny too it's
got to get some good humor to it all
right where is astronomy Tower Nick take
us there want to
know I hope that's the next
one yeah Vault boy I I agree when people
said that before Legacy came out I was
like I don't know I've never played half
Prince so I don't know what the potion
brewing is like and I'm usually not a
not the biggest fan of mini
games but this one they just they nailed
it I'm only complaining now because I've
had to brew them so many times because
I'm going for the platinum
trophy okay wait wait wait wait wait
wait all right the Crest is right
here there's a new
person hello Harry all right what potion
do you want you know how to make a draft
of Peace oh this was a tough one this
was a tough one and the draft's really
hard isn't it uh yeah I'll try and make
get a potions club and then we got to
find the final we got to find the last
person I'm going to have to use the
restroom after this one guys I've been
holding it for so long cuz I'm like oh
we're we're about to be done I'm almost
there the game's like no you're not
you're really not you're you're really
not almost
there out of my way
my goal is to get those final okay hold
up so this is going to give us 123 then
there's another person somewhere for 124
and then there's one more Crest out
there
somewhere that we do not
have wow
man the man just passed
away cuty welcome in thank you for
joining we are in progress making our
way to the platinum trophy here oh wow
that gave us a
lot and the crest collecting is a bit of
a challenge dude Nick why do you keep I
think he switches it up man I don't
think he always takes you the fastest
route sometimes I think he's like I I
just want to make you walk for this one
I'm just going to make you yeah yeah
I'll just make you walk around for a
while nah it probably was the
fastest all right Nick all right all
right you think you know which one M
store oh let's hear it dude I'll try it
we
ar okay draft of peace I believe oh
whoops draft of peace
[Music]
right
okay not draft of living death I really
hope it was draft of
Peace it was draft of peace right
guys let me know let me
know go and start doing it draft of
peace I wish it was peaceful to make I
always end up setting fire to things
this one's not
easy
[Music]
okay thank you King
Tut imagine if we got all the way over
here and
forgot wrong
potion
all right the tough
[Music]
ones
oh my gosh so much shaking on the draft
of
Peace oh come on that's
it
[Music]
what
I remember I lost this one near the very
end
[Music]
earlier almost
there and then this guy right
[Music]
here
[Applause]
okay
all right how do we find That Girl Again
astronomy Tower right that was what it
was close
to come on come on come on all right I'm
taking it back to her and then I'm using
the restroom and then we're finding the
last
one M stor and kisi if you
guys can figure
out which one you think it is I saw
kisia had posted something
earlier oh no wait astronomy tow all the
way up
here so I think if I'm correct I think
we're missing one more of the statues
that is the final potion
one it should be the final potion one
that we're
missing and then we're missing one more
that's just who knows where it
is could be anywhere M has a hunch M
store may know where it
is oh my gosh I have to go go to the
restroom so bad but I refuse to go until
I get this I refuse to go until I
deliver this one right here and then
we'll
go come on come on come on Harry hurry
oh you got to get up man you got to get
up yo jumping toad stool happy Friday
welcome in we just crossed the 5 hour
mark of this stream you
guys I can't believe we be going for
five
hours come on collect collect collect
I'm just going to be like chilling
tomorrow the whole day okay wait it was
at the end of this
Hall I need I need a day of relaxing
after this has been a busy week man lots
of Potter news I posted two videos this
week we've done this is the second live
stream of the week you're great Harry
the
best thank
you all right rest rest room and I'll be
right back and we're going to get this
man these last two we're we're finding
these two right here all right guys be
right back I'm not even putting up the
BRB screen that's how quick I'm going to
be
oh dude M store I hope you're right
there should be one where you need to
lift a bench
upstairs and aim
it towards a
tower oh jumping toad School jumping
toad stool we're so
close you can see it right there we need
two more crests
two more of the big crests and then we
need seven more of the mini crests which
we need 25,000 that's not happening this
stream but that's all we need man that's
all we
need okay lion statue locations oh KY
yes let's go this is perfect okay Hagrid
Shack we got that one entrance
Courtyard oh man where we where are we
at right now we just got the astronomy
Tower one now it says suspension break
Bridge
Okay suspension bridge if it goes in
order then maybe I'm maybe I miscounted
maybe we have
two which would be the final
two oh man I hope I
miscounted please tell me I miscounted
that would be
perfect that would be perfect if they
were the final two thank you kisy by the
way for posting that guys thank you so
much for hanging out today man some of
you have been here for most of the 5
hours
what a stream it has
been but I am determined to at least get
these two in this stream and then I'm
starving I'm going go have some dinner
after
that all right Nick come on my
man so wait this is not suspension
bridge is
it here we are oh this is it this is
it
okay dang it yeah we already got that
one all right so we got that one
Transfiguration
courtyard all right Nick let's try
Transfiguration you you just knew it
wasn't going to be that easy man you
knew it wasn't going to be that
easy back this
wayton At Your Service Sir
Nicholas
easy to have it on the background while
working yeah guys I mean feel free that
that's a huge help to the stream I know
a lot of times I do that too like I just
like to have like just to have something
kind of going in the background
sometimes and I'll throw on some streams
or well I was going to say YouTube
videos but I I don't really if it's a
YouTube video I really want to watch I'd
rather watch that attentively
attentively instead of just having it
going in the background but yeah live
streams then just popping in and
chatting when I'm when I'm available
to oh man so that means the other one is
just hopefully it it m if M door can
give me a little more
Direction on where the bench is that
you're talking about M door I will try
it I know we're at least missing one
more statue because I'm pretty sure
Dylan said it was five potions and five
duels watch and it should be in order
watch so the duel should be
done yeah yeah Roger nick uh oh there
you go now you got it working
Roger it has a different name for you
too now were you on a different account
or something it was M it was showing up
as Mr Ren
earlier but yeah it looks like it's
working now yeah in this game instead of
following the Little Footsteps friend I
must change that password you uh Nick
leads you around
instead all right so this is yes there
it is there it freaking is let's go all
right and it's this person right here hi
s hi I've got to make
some homor but I'm St M Drake it brings
me out in rashes any chance you can help
me uh okay wait which potion Oculus
potion all right Oculus Oculus
Oculus okay take us back to
herbology I wonder if there's a chance I
missed any more statues probably not if
it had to be in
order so that means
there there's one out there somewhere
man one Crest that we're missing oh that
was really quick thank you Nick that was
perfect all right Oculus Oculus
Oculus where is the final Crest you
guys where do you think it
is back seat away for this one by the
way
thetis Cur I'm totally cool with the oh
no this is the one that's going to
require a lot of
[Music]
shaking oh yeah I remember you you took
forever to change
[Music]
color how are you only at 37
seconds we've been flying through
this because you have to
shake
no Oh I thought it was going to start
smoking I know Roger it makes no
sense it's like they wanted to have the
potions Club I guess closer to the
[Music]
ingredients wait another shaking are you
serious right
now no put that
down
more stirring and we got to be quick
we're only at 33
seconds
please I'm so over the potions
please oh come
on please purple purple there it is
there it is now we need to shake you
come on come on come on come on right at
the
buzzer let's go all
right she was in the Transfiguration
Courtyard
right Dylan are you still here by
chance I know Dylan posted earlier about
the the locations for all the Rockets
maybe there's a rocket that I'm missing
the little things you have to
explode because CU we're going to be on
our final large Crest you
guys all right Transfiguration
Courtyard Sir
Nicholas I prefer Sir
Nicholas I don't know why I like
actually like doing that now whenever
I'm running through the
Halls
okay that's a bomb that's not one of
them he hi where'd you go
Nick where'd he go there he
is oh dude I totally messed
up wait Nick how did you let me go that
far
off all right here we
go where was she at oh my goodness
har oh
man this game's so funny I think it was
right yeah yeah yeah right by this
portrait hi thank you maybe this okay
finally get an o in potion one
more
Crest one more Crest imagine if it was
in this
area so Mur was thinking it was one that
I needed to like throw a bench up at a
statue or
something I do remember doing a lot of
that the last one for you was in the
hallway after the viaduct entrance one
where you hit the banners
the first hanging Banner obstructs the
view of the crest as you run towards
it
oo I'll check
that Vault boy I I said the same thing
dude it really does like how the camera
it's like
it like it pulls behind him it really
does look like they they were inspired
by Gears of
War all right it's very possible that it
is one like that so let's do let's do
Viaduct
entrance I'm trying to think of anywhere
else that we haven't really explored
maybe something like the Stone
Circle well hello there well hello
there Sir
Nicholas imagine if it was right right
there just imagine that would have been
So
Glorious I just turn around and there it
is okay I'm pretty sure that I
did I'm just going to hit all these now
just to be
sure yeah we got that
one
armador welcome in hopefully I'm not
mispronouncing that too
bad oh wait so that might be the one you
were talking about okay so we don't have
we don't have a Crest right here so
we're good we're good with that
one I wouldn't go that far armad I
definitely wouldn't go that far but I do
uh I enjoy this one quite a bit it's
probably it's it's up there with Chamber
of Secrets for me
it's my first time ever playing it
actually on this uh this little series
that we've been doing here on our live
streams so let's see uh Callaway that's
probably the one you were talking about
right that hallway that we just went
through Christian gamer dude have a good
one appreciate you stopping by and
hanging
out hey Roger gifting out five
memberships Roger thank you so much man
welcoming in five new members to house R
and tour courtesy of Roger right there
guys make sure you think Roger if you
got one of those gifted memberships now
you have access to our members only
videos you have access to our
emotes we also do uh sometimes members
only Community polls members only
Community
posts hey Martin in the house too Martin
what's up dude welcome but Roger man
thank you so much for real dude it means
a lot Roger has been a longtime
supporter of the stream of the uh of the
channel
here if you guys are just tuning in I
see some new names popping up in the
Stream we are so close ladies and
gentlemen there it is bottom left corner
of the screen right now how are you
welcome to
Griffin bottom left
corner 100
2 how are you welcome to gind 124 now
the other one the one below it the that
one we're going to have to do off stream
cuz that's that's going to take a while
we have to get 25,000 of the mini Crest
so there is a Crest out there somewhere
have you seen my
chog if I bring you a chocolate frog
would you bring me a
Crest new member Friday let's go that's
right I agree mini beef it really does
it really does look amazing for its
time all right where
is I agree whoever said that Kaylee I
agree let's
try the stone I think Stone Circle and
the stone
bridge like did I pick those up not all
of
them yes Steve they have started coming
a little bit faster since I unlocked
there was an upgrade where you actually
unlock more with every
spellcast before I had that I was just
we were when we first started streaming
today I mean we were stuck at like 6,000
or something thinking this is going to
take forever oh is this the Stone
Circle paved
Courtyard Nick I'm just going to go over
here for just a second man
I could see this being a spot where they
hide
one okay let's let's just keep following
him it is also possible that it's one of
the like the the Weasley boxes of
fireworks it is
possible long day almost missed the
stream hey it's been a long stream too
we're at 5 and 1 half
hours 5 and 1 half hour stream
man incendio the vine yeah yeah we we
incendio that vine that has one behind
it
Harry Harry Harry
Potter good boy who
lived come to
die yeah Martin I I absolutely have a a
uh a newfound respect for this game why
it's not that I hated on it I'd never
played it so I didn't
know it just looked so similar to order
of the Phoenix that was just I think I
just wrote it off as a kid like oh man I
don't want to do that again they're
watching us they're all watching I don't
want to do that
again Sarah says hi she's been a long
time
Watcher nice is she is she like a
subscriber here
Steve tell I said hello thanks for the
support oh wait hold on for some
reason I just had a feeling I had a
feeling there might be one wait where at
meor back here
in this
area we did get one earlier M store
launching yeah it was right out there we
got that one that one was kind of crazy
we had to bring a rock in here and
launch it over we did get that
one oh my goodness and Ryan De La Cruz
as
well Ryan what is up
man welcome welcome oh Transfiguration
classroom behind a
banner kisi that that sounds like a good
possibility I don't
remember wait was
that oh we already got that
one I don't even remember going in the
Transfiguration
classroom I'm going to check this area
right here a paved Courtyard or whatever
Stone Circle I forgot what which one we
picked
but do you
want okay that one's clear we already
got that one leave me
alone okay we already did this one I'm
pretty sure but let's just you know what
let's just do it
again yep that one we already
got hey no worries meor appreciate you
trying to
help
appreciate all the help guys oh is this
the stone oh this area out
here I think I've explored this one
pretty thoroughly I know we got this
one okay let's just give a good look
around I want to try kisi suggestion
though I I do not
remember I do not
remember going behind
uh a
tapestry Ryan we need
one more we need one technically we're
we need one more Crest big
Crest but then the the other one I'm not
going to be able to do this stream see
that number down there the 12,150 we
need 25,000 of those that's the mini
crests so all those little ones that you
see flying at me as I run around these
right here yeah we need 25,000 of those
guys so that might be an off stream an
off stream
Pursuit but the big
crests we need one
more one
more
lumos I got to I got to get it in like
the next 20
minutes cuz I got to eat
[Music]
dinner but I think we can do it hey
there's one that's for getting the mini
crests right
there I prefer Sir
Nicholas
all right through the portrait boiled
beetles boiled boiled
boiled wouldn't
they so how many of you in the chat have
been to uh Universal Orlando or any any
of the Wizarding World
parks let me know if you've
been because my last trip was many many
many many many years ago
before they even
added light
againsts and a good morning to you
Harry I know King Tut it's going to be
so amazing all right so here we are now
where is the Transfiguration
classroom never been Roger you're you're
U you're in the US right Roger man it's
it's worth a trip it's not cheap it is
it is not cheap especially if you're
going with like kids or
something or any other family that
you're going to pay for I mean it it's
it's not cheap but it's like it's like
one of those things that at least once
in your life you should try to save up
and
go if if you're a big Potter fan I mean
it's is that good especially after they
open a third Park go away I mean it was
good enough just with the first
one wait where the heck is
Transfiguration
Amelia you've been to Orlando and Japan
wow Steve that's the one we're looking
for right now that is the one we're
looking
for I'm just trying to remember where
the classroom actually is I know it's
like just off the little
uh you know what wouldn't it be
crazy what if it was this
one
oh
man that would have been so
epic wait is this this is not a
Transfiguration
class I'm just collecting the mini Crest
while we're here might as
well jinny you been to the California
one Not Orlando
gotcha oh Callaway that's dude that is a
blast from the past right
there
yes okay this has got to be the
classroom yes okay behind a
curtain wait what curtain or a
tapestry I remember us coming in here
wait wait wait maybe you maybe you guys
mean
this maybe this one oh man I do remember
us coming in here but I don't remember
us finding
one yeah Jenny the California one is is
good like if you live on that side of
the country or close to that side it's
definitely worth
it but then if you ever go to the one in
Orlando you're just going to be like oh
my goodness they just have so much more
space to work with oh above the door no
we already got this
one oh
man
okay let me go to where
is where is the final Crest that'd be
nice wouldn't it
outside the door behind one of the
banners okay we did Stone Bridge we did
Stone
Circle actually we did Stone Circle
let's do Stone
Bridge yeah I think um Steve you might
be were you talking about this one the
one where you have to jump
up we did just do that just to
confirm I did that again just as we were
walking making our way over
here although hold up yeah we did it we
did
it I don't know why guys I feel like
we're missing one of the
fireworks I feel like it's one of those
firework
boxes Clock Tower one behind the bells
yeah we got that
one we got that one for
sure
just double checking this
room okay wait this is the stone bridge
we
arrived oh
man that would have been so awesome if
it was right
there
okay o up there
no
I just I feel like it's outside man I
don't know
why something's telling me the last one
is outside I just don't feel like we've
explored there
thoroughly like we got the one near
Hagrid's
area
oh my goodness are
Los excuse
you clock tower Courtyard
fireworks ooh I yes yes yes that one's
like right by the fountain I
believe almost positively did that
[Music]
one why does she keep asking me that
hey
harry now is there I don't know why it's
not letting me go back into Dumbledore's
office like it shows up on the map but
there's not there's not any way
to yeah Steve that's what I I can't
remember if I did
five I feel like I definitely remember
four
yeah we got the roof of Hagrid's Hut
that was like one of the one of the
first ones I
spotted all right I'm doing
uh I want to go back outside I want to
go like to the Hagrid's Hut area oh man
imagine if it was up
there dude there should be something in
the game like some sort of hint somebody
I can talk
to to help point you in the right
direction fireworks the allery yes for
sure got that
one okay so how many of you asked
Callaway cuz that's that's at least
three you've asked about right
right training
grounds oh two in the paved Courtyard
area clock tower for sure allery for
sure training grounds for
sure for sure for sure on
those and then so you're saying two in
the paved Courtyard
area
I'm just I'm almost positive we've done
this
but hey har doesn't hurt doesn't hurt to
do it
again Clock Tower Dumbledore's office we
can't get back there we've checked
Hospital Wing Hagrid's Hut yes grade
Hall yes we' checked that quidditch gate
yes potions yes you said wait what did
you say paved
Courtyard Sir Nicholas dein pton At Your
Service two in the paved Courtyard
related to
fireworks and then I'm pretty sure we
got all the statue
ones all right I'm setting a time limit
13 minutes if I don't find it in 13
minutes I'm going to I'm going to try
another
day
paved Courtyard up the steps on your way
to a Crest a little ways down second box
will be on your
right oh we okay we we definitely got
the box up
there a little ways down the second box
will be on your right okay wait second
box I don't know if we got a second box
here over here Steve you
think wait wait wait I don't think we
came this way
I don't think we came this
way oh man for a second I thought that
was
it okay wait please please be
it oh we did do this
one we did do this one I'm almost
positive
I'm almost
positive dang it man okay so it's not a
firework
one 100% it's not a
firework boat house maybe I didn't
actually go in the boat house let's go
inside the boat
house thank you King tutd appreciate it
I need the encouragement for
sure I definitely need the
encouragement I knew this would happen
like as you get closer to the end
there's there's always going to be one
or two that are just like really
elusive wonder if there's one by the
tree oh dude remember there was that
mission here in the Order of the Phoenix
game
nothing no ladder or
anything oh I'm stunned there's not one
out
here yeah there was probably one right
there which we
got there's four in the boat
house okay so it was probably that
one then there was the one on the
outside right up there so that's two all
right where would the other four be or
the other two I'm
sorry all right on the wall behind the
boat
house from the previous Crest above the
base of the stairs to the
left halfway upstairs leading back to
the
castle okay wait that would be right
here wouldn't it
or that might be the way that we just
came going to
Wi backside of the boat house between
the stairs and a path isn't that the one
we looked
at I'm just going to go ahead and go all
the way up we'll run back down and
double check
I'm just I'm just going to run all the
way up just to make sure there's nothing
on
here I might be moving too fast too like
I should probably be taking my
time
wait oh I thought thought I saw
something right there man I thought I
saw it for a
second okay yeah now we're back
here all right let's go all the way back
down so Callaway said
backside backside boat house between
stairs and
path Le he said proceed towards the
paved Courtyard on the Rock on the right
behind a
plant yeah I think I know Steve and Ki I
think you guys are talking
about the same
one that I saw on the way
down which we'd already
gotten that's like if you go back up the
other
way but Callaway is right here the back
side between the stairs stairs in the
path that one I'm a little bit not as
clear
on
hry okay so this
is all right so there's that one is that
the one you're talking about the
backside between the
stairs okay so there's the stairs where
where's a path you
oh man I would be so
thrilled I would be so thrilled if we
could find
it
yeah so r that little like plaque like
thing that you see that's that's where
there was previously
one see right
there oh yeah that's Callaway that's the
one right there yeah that's exactly
where you just
said yeah so we got that
one
all right so yeah the one you guys I
think the one you guys are talking about
with the bush is on over
here it's on the side of the
cliff Dylan we got one more man we we're
on the last
one we're searching
everywhere
everywhere we've gotten all the firework
ones
and I'm I'm pretty sure I'm not going to
say 100% sure but I'm pretty sure we got
all of
the the little statue related ones yeah
here's the plant you guys are talking
about yeah so see we got that
one
incendio yep that one's
gone yeah we did the
earlier we did the allery earlier this
stream there were a lot in
there all right guys is there any there
is there supposed to be any in
Dumbledore's office because I can't get
back in
there I'm not sure if you're supposed to
be able to get back in there or not that
one's clear we got that
one
the banners Dylan
that's that's a possible
one how many sets of banners are there
in total the Transfiguration banners
100% we just double checked that one and
then the other uh there was another set
of banners that we just we just kind of
ran through that
area have you noticed
oh there's F oh I bet it I bet it's a
banner
then I bet it's one of the banners if
there are five I don't feel like we've
done five of
those five sets of
them all right so chat throw throw them
out there what do you got what not
Transfiguration we for sure got those
banners throw out any other Banner
options oh dude I wonder if there's any
banners in the Great Hall that you can
hit no looks like you can't jump up and
hit
those o slug Horn's
office
pretty sure on that one but pretty sure
is not good
enough we've got to be
sure we've got to be sure well hello
there okay you can actually thank you
musical King you can't go into his
office it's not loaded in the game it's
only used for cutcenes good to
know Nick where you going dude here we
go man I remember doing that that one in
Slug Horn's
area oh there's two by
Transfiguration all right I actually
think we got the one in Slug horn I'm
going to say seventh
floor I'm going to say seventh floor and
then I'm going to since there are two at
Transfiguration it is definitely
possible that we miss one of
them
come on Dylan be right man be
right be right
Dylan I prefer s
Nicholas okay all right all right all
right all
right oh yeah I think this might have
been the very first one we ever
got I think this might have been the
first one that I struggled with so
much but I'm going to do it
again because you can never be too
sure
oh
yeah all right so that one's
good Transfiguration
Courtyard Sir Nicholas deimy poppington
at
your if I search both of these man and
it's not it
I'm at a
loss it's got to be a spot that we just
haven't
looked I really do not remember doing in
the doing two in the Transfiguration
area
you go from
herbology good morning yeah we were just
traveling all through that area surely I
would have maybe I thought I already had
him though
all right so we know we got that that
lion did not have a
Crest this is the one the one right
around this corner yeah this is the one
that I'm pretty sure this is the one we
just double
checked oh no
okay that one's good all right
herbology come on
Nick come on vault boy Steve come on
Dylan be right please be
right
come on come on come
on this one right here I'm pretty sure
we did this one too but I'm going to do
it again I could be of
service
oh oh come on oh we missed it maybe we
didn't maybe we
didn't is that it Wait no that's it
no no gin
stink
so there's just
three
man usually there's more than three I
thought
one
two
three usually there's one more
but true yeah we're eliminating
more so we just check Callaway we just
checked the seventh
floor anime fan girl welcome thank you
yes it was off the official
uh it fits really well too but it was
off the like
PlayStation I forgot what they call it
PlayStation shop or something the
official
store I don't think there's one in here
do
you we are still on l for the moment I'm
trying to be done there's one more big
Crest out
there chat is trying to help me chat is
lending me their
strength we're searching all over this
Castle the grounds the inside the
outside how do I get to the sixth floor
callow is there something specific on
there cuz you can't you can't set a
course for the sixth
floor yes indeed we do we do yeah there
you go eln and Jenny got it for
you and we got this one
already
maybe the last one
is oh that's
funny if
only it was inside us all
along bro where is that final
Crest okay wait a second does that I did
I definitely did this statue over here
didn't
I feel like I remember doing this
one broken one on the floor in the
library yes pretty sure we did that
one I want to look at this statue right
here yep we got
him Cress by the grand stairs near a
portrait grand staircase we should be
good like I went through there pretty
thoroughly but at this point it it it
very well could be a spot that we've
passed by several times and
just have continued to
miss have you tried out the jeweling
club yet my parents are Muggles okay
right
there I guess we never did double check
the slug Horn's office one so we could
do that
one just to roll that one
out hello hurry oh man if that that
would be great if it was that one
har
I mean it could give off a chime
something they could they could give you
some little
hint as to where it
is but they
won't all slug horns office is on sixth
floor okay
perfect I don't know why when you I just
thought slug horn potions dungeons but
yeah his office is is in a different
spot nothing
there oh come on let me
buy all right guys if it's not this one
I think I'm going to call
it we're over we're over 6 hours now on
the
stream so I'm going to call it after
this
one
but I'm going to get
it I am going to get
it it is just a matter of of when not
if I mean honestly like I could just run
I could just run around the castle
spamming this for the mini
crests yeah I'm almost positive I got
these
but I'm going to do it again
again oh yeah we were just up here
earlier cuz I said that looks like the
rumor
requirement dang
it no luck guys no
luck hey anime fan girl appreciate it
thank
you oh yeah I just saw it pop up I just
saw it pop
up actually hold hold on hold on hold on
let me check something guys let me check
something oh my gosh if there are four
people watching right now who aren't
subscribed if there are four of you
watching right now not
subscribed you can help us hit 60,000
subscribers hey that's nice that's just
for a mini Crest though four subscribers
away you guys from
60,000 K with the super Super Chat thank
you kisi everyone think positive wait I
don't think I've ever been in here come
on please slug horn my
man slug horn are you holding the crest
in here
somewhere please slug horn please please
tell me you got a Crest in
here got
presents slug
horn Jenny with the 15 months uh Jenny
thank you so much for being a channel
member here guys if you
are uh a channel member you get access
to all of our fun little emotes and
access to our members only videos
members
only polls that we do from time to time
it wasn't up here man it wasn't up
here join the club guys join the club I
mean everybody watch it could be
subscribed already they could be
subscribed
you hear that person
screaming come on slug horn how does
slug horn not have a Crest in his
[Music]
office all right I said that was the
last
spot I'm doing one more
spot having fun are we you s was saying
somewhere on the on the seventh floor
I'm going to check that one Len with the
$2 Super Chat as well guys appreciate
the super chats man thank you all for
the
support I think the only Banner on the
floor is the one you get for hitting the
banners on the seventh
floor gotcha got
presents did we hit it I didn't see them
subscribing here but they could
subscribe on oh we did it we did it man
let's go thank you guys maybe they
didn't pop up for some reason but or it
could be people subscribing watching the
videos that's that aren't watching here
on the live stream but we're actually
over it now let's go man let's go let's
go let's
go thank you guys 60,000
subscribers that is a that is a big
number that is a big number people of
the
internet we're going to get 100 this
year this year man
100K we're going to do
it elwin gifting out five memberships
too elwin I think that's I think you
already this stream has been going on so
long I can't remember but I think you
gifted out five to start the stream too
I'm so late oh goodness guys welcome to
house racking
tour welcome welcome
welcome now you have access to all those
emotes courtesy of elwin you have access
to our members only videos courtesy of
elwin special role in the
Discord dude see it would just be
perfect right we we surpass
60k we get a a nice gifted membership
from elen right there and then we end
the
stream by finding the final
Crest come
on banners up here um who said
that yes thank you m thank you for
thaning elwin
man yeah if you guys got one of those
gifted Subs make sure you thank elen
yeah we we hit the we hit these already
man we hit these
already yeah we got that one
too how are you welcome to Griffin
door oh oh
oh are you keeping Nick busy
man Nick is staying busy
oh man I think I think I got to call it
guys like I I don't know where else to
look I think what I'm going to have to
end up doing is just like is just
running
around as I'm collecting all the mini
ones which I'm going to have to do just
like
spamming and just hope that I stumble
across
it
and Dylan with the $20 Super
Chat Dylan my
man thank you so much dude appreciate
that wait did we already hit these twoo
we
did Dylan for real man appreciate it you
guys are the
best process of elimination I know right
I think
that's which it's not I mean it's it's
going to be tedious for
sure but at least we're still like we're
having to collect mini crests anyway so
it's not like we're totally
done it'd be one thing if we were
totally done
already then I would then I would be
even angry angrier more Angry angrier
right I'd be even
angrier already checked there we're good
there
nah we've T we've taken a few breaks
here and there
Maga I don't know why the the little
alerts on screen are so delayed I see it
in the chat long before I see it in
the oh now now all of the subs popped up
there we go thank you guys all of all of
you who subbed earlier that was probably
when I mentioned
it oh come on behind us behind
us this looks like an area we haven't
seen
before come on dude come on come on
we have to end the stream with the final
Crest we have to we have
to clock
tower I'm going to go back this way
what's in what's in here oh you can't go
in there okay yeah the subs were very
delayed thank you guys though pushing us
over the 60k
mark imagine if it was just like sitting
like right in a corner and we just
walked by it so many
times we did get this one right yeah we
got that one a long time
ago H oh
man okay no Crest there we know we're
good on that
one kisi gifted out the five memberships
too oh my goodness let's
go kisi thank you very much for gifting
out those five looks like musical King
DJ never mind gaming Wild Man Gaming Arc
Moon lace yo Moon lace in here lurking
Moon lace what is up passage between
seventh floor and
Potions at the top of the spiral
staircase throw the chest straight AC
across the stairs at the statue in the
window yeah I'm pretty sure I remember
doing that one I remember seeing that
behind the
statue kisi thank you so much man
appreciate
that the membership Community continues
to grow dude if I keep putting the if
you guys have seen in some of our recent
videos I put the members names at the
end of the video I'm going to have to
get like two two lists going where they
scroll at the same
time a a good problem to have though
very good problem to have I'm not going
to complain about that at
all oh wait what the heck how are you
did we ever check this
side oh it just puts you right back at
the top
okayo how are you welcome to
Gryffindor I got this one already I know
I
did I know I
[Music]
did are can't go in
there all right guys I hate to end it
there but I got to end it there I got to
end it there one short man one
short oh geez don't worry if you're uh
I'll post in the Discord or something
when I find it post on Twitter wait wait
wait
wait oh man I thought I thought that
might be it I thought that might be
it all right guys it's been fun I would
honestly I would stay at stream all
night but I I want to visit with the
family and kids a bit my wife has to
work tomorrow
and oh we haven't really had time to
spend any time together today so I'm
going to go hang out with
him Cheyenne watching the stream has
made your day so much better hey glad to
hear it I know Martin exactly dude so
close and so far but we could see the
light at the end of the tunnel we can
definitely see the light at the end
what's going to be bad is if we imagine
if I go through and I get all 25,000 of
the mini
crests and then I still haven't found
the last
one the last big one surely it's not
bugged or something that'd be
terrible that would be
terrible rewards what are the rewards
badges credits yeah we need one more man
we need one
more yeah guys have a good
weekend if you haven't checked out our
video today on the theme park update
make sure you check out that
video I can't wait for that Park to open
it's going to be amazing we also have a
video up that uh is about if you've ever
wanted me to do more lore Wizarding
World lore videos we got a deep dive
into the origin of the Dementors and as
caban which as someone who's followed
the Wizarding World for years I even
learned something that I had no idea
about so it's a dark story man it is a
really dark story but thank you guys all
for the support today 60k Subs man
amazing amazing amazing all the new
members all the uh we had some big super
chats today donations appreciate you
guys very much hope you all have a
fantastic rest of your day have a great
weekend and I will talk to you again
soon thanks
guys